I thought uh someone was will be here
but at any rate let don't we continue
and uh good morning thank you so much uh
to the committee for uh allowing this
time
to revisit this bill and and see what we
can do to make it amenable for um what
I'm seeking as well as uh the goals for
Dees um I did receive a uh an email from
representative Harvey bolia who said she
couldn't join us today um but she has
asked for a replace all Amendment which
is before you um which is very
simple she apparently spoke at length
with uh Miss Darlene forest from Dees
and concluded that the word remove in
current statute is confusing and keeping
people from proceeding with debris
clearing from their streams and at the
risk of putting words in her mouth even
um Miss Forest admitted she didn't know
what remove meant in the
RSA and she stated again that Dees
didn't have jurisdictional authority
over the removal of sticks and debris in
culverts and
streams I looked at this you know if we
just took out the word remove from the
statute
I think that gives a lot more leeway to
a property owner
to have the statutory authority
to remove storm debris
from uh a stream that can be causing
some problems where the stream is being
diverted to damage their their Gardens
their field crops their structures on
their property animal pens and so forth
and I think
um I think that that goes a good way to
um change statute and then Dees can then
go and adapt rules to match
this I would also like to um am amend
this simple change even further to add a
sentence
um because the the RSA
482a colon
3 states no person shall excavate remove
which is the word we want to take out
fill dredge or construct any structures
in or on any Bank flat Marsh or swamp in
and adjacent to any Waters of the state
without a permit from the Department so
that clearly says that you need some
sort of whether it's an emergency permit
or a Wetlands permit that you need a
permit
to do that kind of work I would like to
then add some kind of statement that
says removal of storm debris from a
stream by a property owner is
permissible and does not require a
permit to be absolutely
clear so that's kind of where we are
with this and the rest of the bill I
mean I'd be happy just to scrap the bill
that I submitted originally add this
very small change and I think that that
would cover it um because the goal of my
bill is basically to allow a property
owner to clear a stream out of debris
after a storm happens without having to
jump through enormous numbers of Hoops
through the permitting process and
that's where I am with that so I'd be
happy to ask ask answer any questions
questions okay this is a since this is a
a uh work session it's a little more
informal it isn't the normal card or
anything like that um so does anyone uh
on
the
representative thank you Mr chair good
morning good morning
um to to potentially make your um you
suggested change um a bit broader to
can't handle other cases I wonder if you
consider um except as um supported by or
except except as defined by emergency
removal Provisions uh in rules adopted
by
Dees and then they could put the rules
in that say that they could clear which
is what they said they were going to do
and then it would it wouldn't just be
like maybe there's other cases is where
they need to account for these emergency
procedures not just for not just for
storms okay I mean that that would be
fine too
um the the only issue I have with the
emergency
procedures is that just along with the
rules as well as the paperwork it says
that if you do any emergency work that
you still have to file
um the the regular
permitting
necessary and that says that in in their
rules um i' have to find that but
um I I think I had sent a uh
yeah I have a copy thank you yeah yeah
yeah um so we have
um the emergency author authorization um
3154 and it says you know as well as on
their website with the
directions um that the property owner
you know can or or the well I I'm I'm
concentrating on property owners I'm not
concentrating on um what what a
municipality does because
clearly I think they're different
entities
um but it says that with the um with the
emergency authorization you still have
to
paperwork I have to
here
second
can I point out the piece that I should
see yeah sure on um
3155 where it's um work done during
emergencies without prior
authorization so this is the case
where um you if if your property is in
imminent danger you can stabilize
it and then once you've done that work
you have to report the
work but as I read it as long as you
don't do further work that's you just
have to report it there I just reported
it this is what I did I sent the I sent
pictures in preferably um and then they
say okay that that makes sense that's
with that's if you didn't get that's in
like the extreme case this is like the
emergency case you're you know you've
got a bank that's collapsing and you've
got you know some kind of fence or
something that's going to collapse
it um
okay I but I did see
said so like maybe you've seen 3156
emergency okay I'm looking I'm trying to
find the um Dees Wetlands emergency fact
sheet because
that yeah
okay
um
okay so then
you what what I saw somewhere though it
said that that the um homeowner would
still have to
um submit permits applic a permit a
regular permit application after the um
done in in the in the email you sent on
um on the 18th right um You said I just
quote you um you said as you can see
below in the rule 130 uh
352a a home owner sorry a homeowner May
request an emergency authorization and
then you underlined prior so I think the
prior was the thing that you were trying
to focus on there um prior to filling
out the lengthy and detailed application
is what you said right so I think you're
352a so yeah so a property owner May
request an authorization to act on an
emergency basis prior to filing an
application under ENT WT 310 or 311 so
that says to me me that yes you can get
this emergency
authorization but you have to follow up
with filing the normal
wrong so with with this change this just
small change of taking out the word
remove I think
does a good amount to clarify things but
I think even further
clarification should be some sort of
statement in that part of Statute that
says removal of storm debris from a
stream by the property owner is
permissible and does not require a
permit either an emergency permit or an
regular
permit yeah I I I guess I these seem to
be in in conflict to each other to me
the um the fact sheet which says which
seems to me says that you can fill out
the abbreviated version for emergency
authorization um to get things cleaned
up right but then you don't have to file
file another one and this the line you
just read that says prior like the prior
does make me question but I do wonder if
if uh
we if we could generalize that um uh you
know the statute to to provide ex
exemptions by rule yeah um and Dees were
willing they can testify perhaps or talk
perhaps about how they could CLE clean
up this language and what they int this
yeah this be fine with that okay
absolutely I and I think that is it's
just a matter of clarifying what the
intent
is and if we can do that and accomplish
that I'm a happy
any other
questions or
comments I just have myself I have one
uh just in reading the law as it is now
whether you removed remove remove or not
just the way it reads the way I read it
until I had a chance to really think on
it no person shall excavate fill dredge
or construct any structures and or or on
the bank of any
bank I first read it to mean that This
concerns
structures uh it would be
better in if if we do an amendment to
May to maybe change it to no person
shall construct any structures comma
remove excavate
remove uh fill dredge
in any Bank otherwise to me it it'll as
it exists now it appears that this only
modified what a person could do with
structures and that's not what it's
supposed to be I
presume yeah I I I agree I I think the
language here is very clumsy and it's
not it's not real clear what someone can
do and can't
do you know in terms especially in in um
an emergency situation or a situation
where you've got a a stream that's all
blocked up uh on your property that's
elsewhere is and I'd be happy to you
know work with representative um Harvey
bolia to to um clear up that language if
you
like I would personally I think it would
help okay but uh
the uh the language the additional
language that you're looking to put in
you have
that uh written down or given to do we
have it for the
record I can I'll write it down and give
it to the clerk if you like you would
okay is there anyone uh
well sure is there any other questions
if not I'll see if there anyone else
you Darlene forced just to speak on the
issue when you're ready if there are no
other questions
okay I don't see anybody raising their
hand or uh so yes thank you okay good
thank
you
uh thank you I'll we let uh
representative from
Dees good morning thanks for uh humoring
me this morning on behalf of
Dees again my name is Darlene forc
I the previous 20 some years was the
Shoreland section
supervisor which also covered Shoreline
for wetlands and then in the last two
years have now become the wetlands bu
administrator uh so representing the
Department of Environmental Services on
Wetland bureau's behalf I've distri Ed
this morning a copy of the rules
pertaining to emergency situations which
is ENB WT 315 as well as the emergency
actions fact sheet so that you folks
could see those
today uh she's not here but I do want to
thank representative Harvey bullia for
taking the time um like an hour of time
on an afternoon to contact us and and
discuss and uh Thea is on to kind of
point out what she was hearing from
folks that we might not have been
hearing and one of the things she
mentioned was there's this issue of
remove
um which when the department as you can
see from the emergency action back sheet
when folks call us Woody debris we don't
even think that remove applies to Woody
debris we don't believe it's
jurisdictional because it's not part of
the land at that point it is lying on
the land so it never crosses our mind
but knowing that the issue is the word
remove why is this
issue why why is this a source of of
concern for
folks
um the only place that remove occurs is
in that
statement and I was quite open with
representative bolia that we're looking
at that word remove and we have been as
we go through and are in the process of
updating our rules trying to determine
what that means for our
jurisdiction um I representative rulu as
you mentioned the common makes it weird
it makes it look like you're removing re
the structure there's a comma missing
um absolutely agree with you on that
there is a comma missing um not the
first piece of legislation that's lacked
a comma won't be the
last
so I understand that what's interesting
though is if you read that sentence and
one of the things that we've looked at
is each one no one shall excavate a bank
no one shall fill a bank Wetland Mar you
know Bank Marsh it says no one shall
remove a bank
Marsh or public water doesn't say remove
material
from
um
so I understand wanting to strike the
word remove but we're not certain that
it actually applies to this material
anyway it may not be the change that you
need to affect what you wish to do in
context just grammatically it still
doesn't seem that this would apply to
Woody debris I understand the word is a
hang-up but I'm not certain written you
know read on its plain face English
meaning it means what folks have taken
it
for
so if you remove that word if you strike
the term
remove what you're really striking is
the prohibition on removing a bank
removing a surface water
removing a wetland of marsh which we've
looked at is it might also mean
dewatering and we have had some recent
issues with some gravel mining
operations and other things where folks
have dewatered wet
areas so please understand in context
we're not certain that that word
does what it's alleged to do and I'm not
saying that because I want to you know
undermine representative eron concerns
are very real and and we respect them
and we want to find the best way to
correct
them the rules in chapter 300 are about
to be reopened there are many things
throughout chapter 300 that need to be
fixed and the emergency Pro procedures
in 315 are only one of them we cannot
for the life of us figure out why
private homeowners get 30 days but
municipalities in the state only gets 10
days to report that makes no sense we
would be happy to correct that language
that said is prior to getting an
application prior to filing an
application you may request an EA
because we do not interpret that as you
always must do an after theact
application we filter these as if there
is additional work that you need to do
if you lose a covert for your driveway
if you pull that covert out put that put
the new covert in and back fill over it
there's no work left to be done
therefore all the work was covered under
the EA we do not request an after the
fact application um in part because we
don't have time to deal with the EXT we
try surprisingly enough to not make
paperwork for ourselves that we don't
have to do we require the after theact
reporting because that way if someone
complains we have a record of it so that
we don't pursue things at violation and
make people's lives unnecessarily
stressful
um so we would be happy to to work with
folks on rules we know we have to open
this whole section we know we're going
to be making changes to it because the
time frames there's a 30 to 60 day
limitation on how long you can do the
work we're looking at the 30 60 days and
with the sheer volume of things to be
done the inability to obtain materials
sometimes and it doesn't matter if
you're a homeowner or you're a town
and other than the fact that we give the
homeowner longer to respond everything
else in this is essentially the same
whether you're a homeowner or you're
municipality the rules apply the
same
so there's as I said there's a lot in
there that we know we need to fix um
when you have a widespread disaster
event everyone is competing for the same
resources so giving someone 30 days that
presumes that you can actually find
somebody with the equipment to do it
find the materials you know whether it's
a c rock fill and actually get it done
in 30 days and I also want to you know
point out that when we do this it's not
necessarily from the disaster it's from
the date of discovery on an on emergency
authorization one is you can do work
during the disaster and the other is
where we have so many absentee Property
Owners if you're living out of state and
you come up to your place when things
finally clear up enough that you can get
here and you realize oh this is bad
it might have happened two months ago
but we go by the time of
Discovery
so I I guess where I'd sum this up
is the word
remov or might not mean what it's been
imply to me you might
not we know what the perception is and
we know we need to correct it because
it's causing people unnecessary
stress um but to actually make a change
that's a
fundamental change read that word for
word this still doesn't look like it
applies to Woody debris or trash in a in
a
stream um that said we're happy to work
with folks on the rules we know we're
opening these up um we know that that
process is flawed we are getting ready
to introduce new tools we're happy to
work with you and the rule making
Authority for this is RSA 42
a11 you skip down to it's like five or
it's like Roman 56 or 7 somewhere in
there it says we can adopt rules that
talk about activities that can be can be
conducted without permits that is the
authority that we use to do this um and
it probably is even cited at the
beginning of um the emergency
procedures but we have the tools to make
this happen um and we know that we're
going in to fix them so there is another
method happy to work with folks
um we did this last year with the the
pbn process we're happy to you know if
you guys want to hold this out there to
make sure that we fix that we're happy
to say yeah we're going to fix this and
if we don't fix it you guys are going to
fix it for us um but there's more than
one way to there's more than one way to
approach
this
um just please you know keep that in
question from representative
M thank you Mr chairman thanks for your
helpful analysis on the sentence
construction so a quick question for you
um so I understand representative aon's
constituent concern and and
representative Harvey buo as well um on
the First on that first sentence would
you put the comma after structures or
after
construct
put it after construct because it be
constructed on or in any Bank okay so as
I read this sentence no person shall
excavate in or on any Bank flat right
skip the rest of the series if you want
to really determine the meaning of this
no person shall
remove what onor any so I think the
comma has to go after structures okay
right because I think remove modifies or
references something and and there's no
other something in this sentence besides
structure there's no other object that
remove modifies if if that's my reading
of it right because you don't remove in
or on would make sense you do dredge you
do fill you do excavate in or on but it
almost I think it would be better
constructed as two sentences right you
have two different two different sets of
verbs here one is talking about removing
that modifies I think the intent is
structures what is the verb after remove
Phil problem is that doesn't so remove
being out of sequence with construction
of structures because it wouldn't
necessarily fill up structure you need
two sentences so we've been looking at
it is does it mean remove the bank we've
interpreted it as remove the bank remove
the marsh remove the we've been and I'll
be honest with you like we um remove any
Bank okay so
remove any bank and the in or on refers
to structures as does
construct wow it's a terrible sentence
yes it is no one's going to argue that
so so I see so I see there's multiple
problems because you could actually read
it no person shall
excavate any
Bank remove any Bank fill any Bank flat
Marsh
swamp construct or remove any structures
yeah it's a terrible s we really really
good
with sir uh can we get everybody
involved in the conversation it's a it's
a subcommittee work session or are we
having a new public hearing it's a sub
work session so informal discussion is
definitely appropriate for what it's
1968 the word remove had been alter and
that was decided to be a little too
restrictive so the word alter in the
and and what I'm hearing you say is it
it's it's immaterial in terms of the
intent of this legislation because you
never had a never met it to refer to a
bunch of debris that washed into your
Culvert which is essentially a seasonal
stream yeah that's we don't consider
that to be a part of the actual resource
itself so it's either in your opinion if
I I don't mean to put words in your
mouth but in your opinion it's either
not necessary or we could use this
opportunity and use this legislation as
a vehicle to correct those sentences or
you can do it in rules um this is
representative Aaron's legislation with
representative aon's purpose so I don't
want to hijack representatives langu to
like fix a problem that she didn't mean
to fix so I don't think it's fair for us
to s for for Dees I don't think it's
fair for Dees to do that but I don't
think this as a this wording issue is
not necessarily the solution to the
problem representative Aaron is trying
to
solve
gu representative B for
question thank you Mr chair good morning
um thank you for coming in and taking
our questions so I've been so this for
the second time this morning um you said
that there's going to be a new way of
reporting coming up an app or something
like that so I had some questions about
how that would speed the matters
up um and what the flow of um like the
chain of custody of the information
would be once somebody says oh there's
something wrong in my yard I got to do
something about it and takes a
picture of what happened and sends it in
thank you we have been using um we have
been adapting an online e filing
process to create a tool in which people
can come
in it can be the owner or it can be an
agent on behalf of the
owner create a file list the address of
the site in question list the contact
information for the person who owns the
property or who's going to be doing the
work they'll have the option of actually
using a mapping tool where you can zoom
to the area put a dot on a
map they can explain what they're going
to do just type in in a narrative this
is we need to replace the cber here and
they can upload the
photo if they're doing it as an after
Action Report they can upload the before
photo there is no fee associated with it
once it's once they upload everything
all the fields are completed the map dot
is optional if all the required fields
are
completed then they can hit send that
will come into us we will log that into
our
database um I've got to be honest up
until this past spring or actually I
guess it would probably be about
November of last year these were all
handled do disaster events and they
weren't logged in the wetlands normal
database which meant tracking them
afterwards and figuring out who did what
wear on some of the 2021 Disaster
Response and trying to get paperwork out
to people to file their applications or
their insurance or whatever they needed
it
for was hard it was far we made that a
lot more difficult on ourselves than it
had to be so now that will be logged
into our database which means we can
show where all the after action damage
is which helps us report out
later um but once they send that to us
we'll log it in we'll then send them a
confirmation letter that identifies
either the work you did the work you did
complies with 3154 or 3155 no further
permitting is necessary the work you did
wasn't even in our jurisdiction thank
you for reporting it you definitely are
in compliance with Wetlands rules rules
of law uh the work you did complied
please note if you need any additional
work the future work will require a
permit or there will be some that will
say yeah that did not comply we have had
some folks who have done some things
that didn't fit that process that didn't
comply and you should be submitting an
application for that but we will then be
able to send them a cover letter we'll
send them a response that closes that
door for them and gives us a permanent
record so that if anybody calls us and
said you know like hey I got back from
vacation and this happened or my
property was being damaged and I'm
blaming that work over there even if it
was that work it was legal like we can
put to bed future complaints we can
track where we have weak spots in the
system uh but it will be there is no fee
there is no it just gives them a way
that they can load everything in hit
send uh we can log it and give them a
closure thank you that was very
helpful representative Darby for another
question or statement yeah thank you Mr
chair I have a few questions if it's
okay um first off I I think you just
explained why the prior word I hopefully
people can hear me I think you just
explained why the word prior is in
352a which is that there are some cases
which is where the work wasn't compliant
where you do require the full process
but you know to representative aon's U
Point um it looks um it looks uh
excessive in most cases and in fact it
doesn't even seem like it's required in
many cases so in the work um would you
consider uh would you imagine the
department considering rewarding that to
make it more um obvious when those cases
would be when you Revis these when you
re um reopen these Ru rules yeah I've
already made a note to do that yeah we
will definitely that's that's an easy
fix and we will definitely add something
we will strike prior out of there and do
an
after um we'll put something at the end
that says if additional work is to be
done in fact I think that's picked up in
the a actions after emergencies at
3156 um anything that's needs to be done
after the emergency has ended we can
expand that to say that's where your
application is necessary great my second
question was you said that you're going
to reopen them what's the timeline
you're looking at for that well I had
wanted to have the first draft of that
available to staff
um uh Thursday of last
week which would have put us before the
Wetland Council in February which is our
first step before actually going into
the process uh we want them adopted by
September or
October of this year so we look at all
of we look at changes to 300 as a
critical operational issue for us um so
it's a high priority for us and this is
just one of the this is going to be
added into that high priority list of
changes okay great thank you my last
question is with respect to um you know
represent Aaron's um concern that the
the wording in the statute is pretty
black and white it says you know you
need a permit but there are cases where
you don't need a permit um which are you
know um in emergency you know response
situations would would you be would you
think would you be um accepting of you
know some language um at the end of that
sentence that said something like accept
emergencies I think that's probably too
restrictive because that's going to let
people think they need a permit only if
there's an emergency when in reality you
have additional except exeptions further
down in A3 there's the world's longest
sentence um down below so perhaps even
broader except as Exempted by rule by
okay right are you finished yes thank
you sorry representative done for
question or question in your opinion do
you feel like this bill is necessary or
can you fix it through the rules
now okay so in your opinion this bill is
not
necessary we have yeah
correct thank
you that's our decision I know I
know you know representative harb thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking
this question I actually have two where
we're talking about floods emergencies
but am I incorrect at any time can I
remove Woody debris a trash at any
time okay my second question is would it
be appropriate if it's not already in
the regulations to just add a sentence
somewhere that says specifically Woody
debris or trash in a stream can be
removed without a
permit if you chose to do
that I would suggest the place to do it
is further down in A3 there's a list of
exemptions that's already
there
[Music]
um as I said we have the world's longest
sentence which is comprised of a whole
lot of things that are
exemptions in fact most of A3 there's a
series of exemptions with an A3 that
would be the appropriate place to put it
if you wish to do
so thank you
anyone
else if I may I would just say one thing
experience we have had some applications
once
um we have had applications where folks
have actually gone onto Lake beds and
recovered artifacts under the guys that
it was
trash
um when you choose to if you choose to
do that
language um there are many wrecks on the
beds of lakes in New Hampshire that are
tourist attractions and dive sites that
are
technically public trust so if you're
going to say something about trash you
might just want to make sure that you
don't create a loophole where someone
goes down and actually takes something
that's part of the state's historic
Legacy shall we say um that would be the
only thing I would caution on that
representative Darby thank you um Mr CH
and the and the other thing about Woody
debris um so on private property clearly
I mean I'm I'm not arguing against that
but there's um you know I I I'm on the
public water advisory access Advisory
Board and I was down in uh at the niss
uh River Management um and one of the
things that is a real area of contention
is removing Woody debris in streams in
uh rivers rivers that are um where
people canoe because fishermen want it
and canoeists don't want it so it it
would need to be the exemption would
need to be specifically on private
property as opposed to people thinking
they can just go pluck this stuff out of
any
River that is the most common request
that we get about Woody de breze from
canoe and kayak groups who want to do a
river we go down this River we'll get a
call yes we go down this River all the
time there's a log Jam it's a hazard
someone's going to get hurt we want to
pull it out and the first thing that we
ask is do you own the
land and many times they don't and we'll
tell them to get the permission of the
landowner and the landowner will refuse
depending on what the land owner's
interest is so that is a
valid riverbeds are privately
held
and you do have to unfortunately not all
the people are going to
respect that they don't own that they're
just going to want to continue to canoe
down
it so that is a valid point of caution
by representative
Derby okay representative Aaron you had
a comment concerning that D
representative Darby's
question
talking Woody debris yeah I'm not just
talking about Woody debris after a storm
you get a lot of rocks
silt uh vegetation that's been ripped up
from
Upstream that's that's also part of this
debris that that results from flooding
and storm
damage and
hearing the emphasis is just on plucking
out Woody debris and I don't know that
that's that i' want to limit it to that
that's not what I was just trying to
respond to that one thing and and I
think I don't want to speak for
representative harb but I heard
representative harb say since Woody
debris is not called out maybe it needs
to be explicitly mentioned someplace I
don't think we're trying to under under
estim emphasize at all the ability to
restore the stream bed where you where
you need to right yeah okay just so
clear
on thank
you
do you
have your name am I okay to speak from
here yeah go ahead sure Kevin Nyan I
work at the Department of Transportation
and the environmental Bureau I manage
the environmental Bureau there I think
it's important um as we're talking
about what you you know what is
allowable without notifying Dees after
or during an emergency I think it's
important to be clear that um I think
the rules you know except in the fact
that maybe there's some language that
could be clarified that removing Woody
debris and accumulated debris from a
stream by a by a private land owner is
something that is is not harmful per se
you know but as we're talking
about um removing rocks or or relocating
rocks along a stream bed or or or
without notifying Dees or putting a a b
Bank back without an emergency
authorization so something that Dees is
aware of that could have ramifications
for Downstream infrastructure so for
example if we're if we're talking about
uh a private property a private land
owner who's not just
stabilizing what happened because the
emergency right so stabilizing would be
you armor with you know what's left or
something like that in an emergency that
I that I completely understand but if
we're talking about taking that stuff
and putting it back what happens if
there's a state asset Downstream a
bridge for example that's been
undermined the abutments are undermined
and it's precarious as it is if Upstream
land owners are now putting that stream
back to where it was without
notification or without de's involvement
who can say oh I understand what you're
trying to do but you need to be aware of
this Downstream or in that case Dees
notifying do in this example that that
there's going to be some work that isn't
coordinated you could have the
unintended consequence of negatively
affecting that uh that um compromised
infrastructure Downstream so I think if
we're talking about cleaning out a
stream channel to make sure that it can
flow or
stabilizing uh stabilizing property
after or during emergency I think the
rules adequately deal with that now but
if we're talking about putting something
back without notification or
coordination with Dees I think that can
become a real problem for Downstream
sensitive
infrastructure um if I can that there is
a gentleman that has contacted us on
this December floods out
of sandag and Country Club um don't
think it's in Borum but it's it's up
there in that neck of the woods who
tried to build a levy as the water came
up um he did get it done he did put the
river back in its Channel but not before
the river did a significant amount of
damage his request to us was when is the
state going to come and fix the
river because his point was he couldn't
do it he just didn't have the money to
do it and it didn't matter if he did
anything to the river on his property
the part of it he owned if the person
Downstream didn't do anything and the
person Upstream didn't do anything and
they everybody did their own
thing if the gist of this bill is that
every homeowner gets to go in and move
sediment we're not talking about Woody
debris
anymore that every homeowner who has the
means to actually move
material not every homeowner is going to
have that goes in and does what they
want to their portion of the riverbed
that they
own which after some of these floods I
don't even know where the property line
is because River start to make you know
the the new channels Channel changes I'm
not even going to go get into how a
surveyor figures out the center line of
the channel
anymore everyone goes in and does what
they think is right to take care of
their property not to do what's right
for the river I'm going to make sure my
property doesn't get damaged then the
person Upstream the person Downstream
the person across the river from
you you're going to end up with a bunch
of people that are doing work that's
counterproductive to one another I do
not have the solution to this but I can
tell you environmentally scientifically
rivers are Dynamic systems you cannot
get that River to do what you want one
property at a
time one of the big things I mentioned
we are behind the game on this flood
issue
is how do you how do you address the
system as a
system this cannot that is one of the
things that's fundamentally wrong with
this is it cannot be every every man for
themselves to see what
happens and if it's roulette someone is
going to have their property damaged
it's not going to be because someone was
trying to be mean to their neighbor it's
because these things are Dynamic systems
that are hard to predict and seldom do
what we think they're going to do it
requires a coordinated response the
Wetland statute opens
with we recognize that the peac meal
unregulated impacts to these systems to
Wetlands to jurisdictional areas will
result in it lists a series of negative
things it is the peacemeal nature of
that that is not that would be something
that the wetlands Bureau would ADV would
inform you would be very
dangerous it's not that we're going to
Advocate we're just going to tell you
experience shows if
everybody goes in and does their thing
on the limited part of the rivered along
its reach that they
own it is not the river is it's not
going to solve anybody's problem you're
just going to make new problems for
other people that's the thing that's
missing yes there's a problem yes
material is
deposited it's no one has the problem is
everyone on that section of the river is
under stress and you don't have time and
you don't have me and there's a lot of
ation that comes
out but there needs to be a coordinated
response to addressing these River
issues not every man for themselves and
I don't know what the answer to that is
I know do has been involved with several
projects in different towns that we've
been trying to help and consult on but
it's a systematic problem that covers
multiple
properties and there's not really mean
right now coordinated
response do I have the answer no but
it's the coordinated response that
doesn't create a problem that's missing
I don't know how to build that but
need I think we're going a little I
think we're kind of gone a little bit
further than this uh bill I think
intense uh but that's my personal
opinion all right we uh
of this is put this to the committee
where we go from
here I mean this is not an executive
session so uh just uh think on what we
might want to do with this bill uh there
is a uh we are we looking for an
amendment I thought we were at an
amendment early on but I think we might
have moved away from that I'm not
certain
uh representative rung for remember we
only have a couple of minutes okay thank
you Mr chair I think uh when Miss forse
mentioned that there may be a good
solution to this without having to pass
legislation that there could be some
adjustment to the rules I'd like to
perhaps ask representative Aaron if she
and Miss fores could you know maybe work
together on that rules change to make
sure that any change um addresses the
the the problem that these homeowners
event
say change rules
but that's why I think it needs to be
clear made clear in the
RSA what a homeowner can cannot do in
the event of De beinging up a stream on
all right remember we got two minutes
now okay I mean I I um my preference of
course maybe not of course but would be
that this was handled by rules but I
respect um representative Aaron and
representative uh Harvey buy as as
perspective that an amendment would help
it I think that the combination of what
um representative har F buy put together
as well as you know M another minor
change to I that like I was discussed
earlier um I think would would wrap this
thing up
honestly okay represent representative
wolf or comment I'm concerned one
minute we have one minute okay okay I'm
concerned about putting changing one
word now because of the repercussions
that came from that we've heard all
kinds of things I think it would be
unwise to remove one word When Miss
Frost said they interpret it another way
I think we need to clarify that
interpretation and then maybe a an
amendment won't even be
necessary but I'm scared to start
time
Y for the for the first time
yes go ahead y representative given the
amount of information that we were
presented with today that's additional
the fact that there may be some kind of
a non-legislative
solution but also the concerns of some
of the committee members that we do need
legislation so I'm just wondering if
there's if we would if it's possible to
time uh this I do not have this bill
scheduled for uh executive session so we
do have more
time you know except we do eventually
have crossover time and then the bill
yes so we we have to we have into March
if we do if we wish to do it I would
rather not spend that amount of time
but you know it is available now it is
not I next week we have an executive
session this bill is not on it a lot of
other bills are including the bills
we're going to be hearing now
so last wrap it up I just um mention
that um Miss Forest I believe said if we
wanted to hang on to the bill send it to
interim study um that way they'll have
the Draft rules out um so that they can
start the process like she described we
we can all and representative Aaron can
look at those draft rules make sure that
they um meet the intent um and then we
can decide a you know after the summer
if the Draft rules be they're moving
represent or sorry um Miss Forest said
they were moving very quickly on this
and we could just sort of hold on to it
minute all right we I will close
the uh the work
session and I yeah it well that says
you oh oh we go by Verizon Standard Time
let's yeah give subm minute while we
change
over
I'll open the hearing of on House Bill
1143 including control of cyano bacteria
blooms under the New Hampshire clean
Lakes
program chair recognizes representative
rung as the prime sponsor okay thank you
very much Mr chair and thank you
committee I'm happy to introduce House
Bill
1143 this bill um came out as a as a
result of a report that the state issued
um regarding ccio bacteria management
and um there's the suggestion from the
uh DS in that report and also with input
from a uh citizens or Community advisory
panel was to incorporate
cyanobacteria into um current statute
which um outlines the clean lat program
so you you'll see in the Bild um where
specific uh uh paragraphs are added that
address the needs for C uh the needs and
strategies for cyanobacteria
mitigation um DS is here I'll let them
speak in more detail they're probably
better app um in a better position to
answer questions but I do want to alert
the committee that within the hour there
will be an amendment to this bill and
the specific changes that the amendment
reflects is that um there'll be language
pertaining to the issuance of permits
for inl management projects including
but not limited to the use of chemical
or physical inl treatments for the
specific purposes of preventing or
remediating cyanobacteria blooms and
then there'll be a strike out of
language that's in the very um end of
the bill that
says
um uh chemical applications or physical
treatments shall be made in consultation
with the fishing game department and
shall be implemented with or without the
concurrence of the Department of fishing
game that last phrase is going to be
deleted it'll just end with Shelby made
in consultant with fishing game
department so I expect that any minute
that amendment I I won't wait until the
executive session to to share that with
you it should be ready soon but I'd be
happy to entertain any questions because
as I said there are officials from uh
Dees that are here that are going to be
in a better position to answer your
questions okay there any questions by
members of the
committee will you entertain putting
giving us a oh I will yes sorry Mr
chair repres representative Darby thank
you Mr chair thank you representative R
thank you um so this is uh you know it
says the department shall be directed to
reduce nutrient inputs but then it seems
that it's really there the focus is two
things education and then in the case of
lakes where chemical treatment might
make sense to do that of course there's
lots of lots and lots of other ways that
phosphorus can be you know nutrients can
be reduced but that you really just
trying to limit DS's scope to these two
areas um thank you very much
representative for the
question you know there is an array of
issues with Lakes there's a lot of
phosphorus that appears from outside the
lake that through runoff or erosion that
gets into the lake fertilizer runoff is
a good example or septic system failures
we've talked about that can add
phosphorus in but then there's also
lakes that um they just have phosphorus
that enters the water column from
internal loading so phosphorus that may
naturally be found in the sediment of
the lake under certain conditions where
oxygen levels might get very low um that
phosphorus can be released into the lake
and and add so there there's some Lakes
where you could reduce all of the
external loading but still have excess
phosphorus from the internal loading so
what what this bill is is doing is it's
just allowing de s to formalize any
cyanobacteria response that's needed
Lake by Lake because every Lake's going
to be different and and get that into
statute so that rules can be drafted to
support the work that's done to mitigate
cyanobacteria blooms does that answer
your
question for a followup thank you Mr
chair just but you're you mentioned some
other cases you know fertilizer so on
and so forth but you're not trying to um
Pro allow Dees to you know limit provide
restrictions or rules regarding that no
many of the activities that are used to
mitigate
phosphorus um from entering a lake those
are are typically identified through a
watershed management plan which is a
scientific study that's done on the lake
there's usually many water quality
analysis that's done on the lake and
they can determine what specific issues
face that Lake and offer remediation
projects and um this just allows Dees to
oversee all of those
projects um and be able to um make sure
that they're addressed in a in a
formalized
cohesive strategy to to you know and I
think it also and I don't want to put
words in DSS mouth but it it makes them
a partner in that work for instance you
could have a Lake Association that
develops a watershed management plan for
their Lake and they can go and do things
but this what this bill would allow is
to um are um specify how Dees can can
become a partner in that process and and
get their involvement it's actually very
much crafted and and the clean Lakes
program actually got started I think um
to address aquatic invasive species and
to get Dees involved in that process and
so CYO bacteria is is just being added
on to that clean laks
program is that answer
okay representative wolf you thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question you talked at the very
beginning about naturally occurring
phosphorus in a lake that's natur
overloaded does this
give the dees or anybody else the
authority to alter an existing thing
because maybe some of that phosphorus is
creating and I don't know um blooms
because of temperature changes and
things like that uh so is it
allowing somebody to alter a naturally
occurring cause of CYO blooms cob
bacteria blooms yeah thank you very much
for that question representative yes
having this in statute allows Dees to um
develop rules and and permitting
guidelines for an in-lake treatment that
would prevent that phosphorus that's in
the sediment from entering the water
column I mean up until you know several
years ago phosphorus that was in the
sediment stayed in the sediment and the
oxygenation of the water happened
naturally through the lake turnover but
what we've seen the trend is that um
water isn't getting as cold in the
winter and it's warming up very quickly
in the spring and it's causing a
temperature striation in the lake so the
bottom water isn't getting pulled up and
oxygenated it's because it's almost like
we're having temperature layering in the
lake so you may have the top layer that
turns over but the bottom layer doesn't
it's very inefficient and it gets
depleted of oxygen just from organic
matter that may be at the bottom of the
lake that's um decomposing and and using
oxygen or it could be fish that might be
at the bottom that are consuming oxygen
but the water at the bottom of the lake
becomes what's called anoxic it's very
low oxygen and under that
chemical um situation the the phosphorus
that's normally bound to other elements
in the bottom of the sediment becomes
released and so there is there are
several inl treatments the one that's
most common and the one that New
Hampshire has some experience in with um
Kaiser Lake and nippo lake is they um do
what's called an Alum treatment and they
take a lot of water measurements it's
it's a very uh complex process to um
calculate the dosing of Alum and there's
a company that comes out and they after
they acquire all this data on the lake
they spray Alum on the surface and that
Alum Goes Down And as it's going down to
the sediment because it's heavier than
water it's picking up phosphorus but it
also creates what's called A Flock at
the very bottom of the lake and it that
flock is serves as a chemical barrier
maybe even a physical barrier I'm not
sure but from phosphorus from from
entering that water column and then
triggering these cyanobacteria blooms so
this inl treatment yes it is preventing
the natural release of phosphorus but
that phosphorus historically was not
naturally released it's because of the
oxygen levels that stayed in the
sediment so by addressing in Lake
treatment in this statute it allows Dees
the ability to um to apply that through
rules and permitting to be able to
specify that I hope I didn't is did I
answer your
question you need to have the inl
treatment to um prevent the in Lake
answered
so for an additional question no it's
it's a follow through followup if I
may thank
you so in certain
cases we may be messing with Mother
Nature and what is occurring
naturally exactly Mother Nature under
the warming Trend we've seen is um
phosphorus is changing its chemical I
don't want to get too technical but it's
being released from this bond with other
metals and it's going into the water
that's nature that's chemistry we we
want to alter that chemistry so that the
phosphorus stays at the bottom of the
lake and Alum is a natural chemical it's
found more question represent mon thank
you um and is some of that old sediment
or organic matter it may not actually be
natural but it may be from um deposits
made by humans decades ago so it's not
necessarily part of the natural original
state of the
lake yeah true that that's true
represent L Montaine thank you for the
question it could be just a buildup of
leaves and and Woody material that we
talked about at during our work session
you know it just gets into the lake it
blows in some people unfortunately dump
a lot of their yard waste in Lakes um uh
we we people work hard to prevent that
but yeah so that's you say that's Mother
Nature it's natural material didn't get
there through Mother Nature sometimes
maybe it did but um and I I do want to
stress that many leges that are
experiencing chronic cyanobacteria
blooms may not even need an Alam
treatment um it's a watershed management
PL would identify those strategies that
could lower phosphorus just through um
mitigation projects like rebuilding a
culvert um changing the slope of a of a
road that might go along or driveways um
building up vegetation I I mean we we
had a bill earlier about just the
vegetation along the shoreline and
people violating the shoreline
protection act because they're taking
off vegetation which is increasing
erosion
runoff um many times we can help Lakes
by making sure those activities don't
happen um and really strengthening the
enforcement of the shoreline protection
act so that may those may be enough that
Alum treatment is really the last ditch
Resort um to Stave off the phosphorus
blooms that answer your
questions seeing
none thank you
and
pass and thank you thank you uh David
Neils
andaron
Dees good morning I'm Aon Holmes The
Watershed Bureau administrator at the
Services morning Mr chair morning
committee members my name is David Neils
I'm the Chief Quantic biologist at Dees
and I'm also director of the jod Conor
anology Center I'm passing around
letters of testimony and a couple of
copies of the exe executive summary of
the CYO bacteria plan so I'm happy to
share those with you I believe those
were emailed to you uh previously so you
should have them in your
inbox um here uh with the opportunity to
testify on HB uh
1143 which expands uh New Hampshire's Uh
current Clean laks Program which is
authorized under RSA
47 the department supports this bill and
uh I'm going to offer the following
information for the committee to
consider and I'm happy to answer some of
your questions scientific or otherwise
at the end I've worked at De for 23
years 11 in my current capacity as a
chief of quic
biologist over that time I've been
intimately involved in tracking cob
bacteria blooms across the state and
responsible for the development of our
current program uh that monitors and
reports on Sono bacteria blooms I can
say without hesitation that uh CYO
bacteria currently represent one of the
greatest threats to our surface waters
in the state of New Hampshire uh to date
we have blooms on 122 uh water bodies
that have been documented uh each of
these water bodies have had a warning
issued uh which restricts uh Recreation
advisory is advisories are issued or
Warnings are issued protect the public
uh pets and livestock from the toxins
that cyob bacteria can
produce warnings typically last about 25
days but as we saw this summer uh some
of them last over a 100 days so they can
last Almost the majority of the
recreational
season during that time our department
recommends against the use of the water
body for recreation and in certain cases
when they occur on Public Water Supplies
there can be uh concern relative to the
uses of the water body for water supply
use in response to the increased
prevalence in severity of Soo bacteria
blooms over the last several years as I
previously mentioned the uh the
department completed a Statewide cyob
bacteria management plan uh that was
done in conjunction with a cyob bacteria
advisory committee the plan outlines
several strategies recommended by the
department to reduce and control C on
bacteria
blooms as a primary author of that
report it was clear from the outside
that the reduction of nutrient inputs
needed to be one of the primary
strategies included in that plan
nutrients specifically phosphorus are
one of the most important factors that
cause cob bacteria plumes and represent
the one thing that we can control with
respect to factors that really influence
the occurrence of Sino bacteria Bloom
specifically the report recommends the
expansion of the clean Lakes program
which is under RSA 47 again as an
important component of the strategy to
reduce nutrients in our surface water a
little bit of background about the clean
Lakes program it was enacted in 1990
specifically specifically states that it
shall function to limit the utopic
process which is the speeding up of Lake
aging which is primary done primarily
done through the addition of nutrients
to reduce uh nutrient grow or nuisance
growth of macron which is plants quatic
plants and phytol plon which includes
cyanobacteria phytol plon is just algae
and cyanobacteria for a long time are
classified as an algae further statute
states that uh its purpose is to
diagnose degraded lakes and Implement
long-term solutions to restoring water
quality which I think is consistent with
uh what this uh proposed legislation
recommends it also uh States as a
purpose to provide short-term remedial
actions which can effectively maintain
water quality conditions for adequate
adequate for public Recreation enjoyment
over the past 20 years most of you
probably know this the state the statute
has focused exclusively on the
management of invasive aquatic species
primarily plants with exceptional
success um however the statute clearly
identifies that the restoration and
preservation of projects that control
reduce incoming nutrients that also be
considered including watershed
management planning which representative
rung previously spoke about the proposed
changed would further emphasize the need
to monitor manage and reduce the risk of
cob bacteria blooms specifically as part
of that
statute additionally the proposed
legislation directs the department to
control the level phosphorus using in
Lake management techniques where
possible and based on sound science it's
not something that we uh um expect to be
doing on a regular case but or a regular
basis but we do know that there will be
certain instances where it's
necessary the department feels that the
proposed change is an important step in
adding updated policies and practices
that will facilitate the understanding
and reducing the amount of phosphorus
loading into laks played by cynobacteria
blooms and that is consistent with the
cynobacteria plan
we are pleased to see that the
legislators considering uh one of these
specific recommendations of the plan if
passed it will compliment the use of
current funding available in the cob
bacteria mitigation loan and Grant fund
that was established in
2022 importantly it also establishes a
framework for the future use of
additional funds that may become
available through specific uh specific
to reducing phosphorus loading to lakes
and remediating CER bacteria
blooms I can't stress enough that the
management of cyanobacteria in our
surface waters is a complex problem that
requires multifaceted approach the
current legislation if passed is an
important step in expanding the tools
that we have in our toolbox to to reduce
the occurrence and severity of sinob
bacteria
blooms I want to also uh uh note that we
are recommending that or we're also
supportive the language that
representative rung uh suggests it will
be introduced as an amendment uh one
which would give the the authority to
develop rules under RSA 47 colon 24 and
those rules would be specific to
implementing in Lake management projects
our current process is not perfect um
and the use or the development of
specific rules designed to uh manage
such projects would be uh greatly
enhanced the current rules that we use
are really designed for surface water
discharges similar to what we you would
be familiar with with wastewater
treatment plants and this is is quite a
different
situation um we also are supportive of
the specific language which uh will be
introduced in the amendment with regards
to fishing the fishing game department
we feel like the fishing game department
is an important partner in any uh large
scale in Lake treatment project that we
would Undertake and in fact we're
currently considering an in Lake
treatment project uh for particular Lake
in this in the state of New Hampshire
and one of the first calls that we made
was to reach out to fishing game we've
already undertaken some consultation
with them in that
matter and that's all I have I'm happy
to answer all of your scientific
questions to the best of my ability um
so I welcome any of those questions
thank
you
uh Erin Holmes you wish to say anything
or you're you're there you're there to
you're there to watch
it
yeah um I have uh one one question
uh I don't see a any uh money associated
with this yet it says it's effective
date is 60 days after
passage uh do you have money or do you
just put this put out a 10 cup
to I mean where's where where's the
money coming from and who who pays
that's that's an excellent question Mr
chair and uh one that you know we we've
anticipated um we there are monies
available now in the cyto bacteria
mitigation Loan Fund and the rules that
were just passed um we anticipate that
those funds would be one of the primary
mechanisms that we would utilize to uh
Fund in Lake treatment projects this
particular uh proposed legislation goes
goes a bit further and establishes a
framework for uh further developing the
clean Lakes program and would also offer
the opportunities should there be
additional funding offered in the future
or proposed in the future to uh allow
that funding to be included here so um
we're not anticipating any specific
funds relative to this particular
legislation and we anticipate using the
available ask my I'll ask myself if I
can have another question yes I think I
will
uh is this uh uh is the money coming
just from uh Dees or is this a shared
responsibility with the folks who will
benefit from it which are those who live
around the
lake uh I I guess I your question is
this relative to the cyob baceria
mitigation fund yes yes um right now the
way the the rules are set up and
established there is no uh required
match to uh to to receive those funds
however we would anticipate as we review
projects that there would be a large
amount of work in in advance of that
that would require a significant
investment by the entities living around
or benefiting from the particular
project thank you any uh questions by
anyone from the uh
committee so you all know the science
right good fantastic what else do you
know ah good
question thank you Mr
chair um I'm still hung up on
this more of a better word messing with
Mother
Nature I look back 20 odd years years
ago when we said oh we're going to put a
conservation easement on the headwaters
land
14 140,000 Acres it's going to be there
and the loggers are going to continue
Etc we never understood about carbon
credits the world has
changed and I wonder whether this
treatment of the phosphorus that's
naturally occurred is there are we doing
it maybe because we want pretty water
for people that live around the
lake it's a concern that I have Mr chair
and I just don't have an answer yet
representative wolf I truly appreciate
your question and in fact uh a lot of
times when I work with my colleagues in
the department uh we have received a lot
of requests to improve water quality
conditions in the lake and one of the
first things we say to ourselves is our
lakes and ponds are not pools um if
people are expecting a pool condition
they should go install a pool on their
property enjoy a pool um the the
question that you posed uh earlier to
representative rung and the one I think
you're sort of similarly asking here is
when we review the conditions in a water
body we consider what its historical
state is or was and we do that by
looking at some of the uh prior um
reports that were done on trophic
classification that's sort of sets the
threshold by which we expect a water
body to behave and the water quality to
um to exhibit um so that's kind of the
the expectation that we have it's not
one that we feel is
unreasonable and we also know that as I
mentioned previously nutrients are one
of the things that we have the ability
to control the amount of nutrients that
go into a lake uh whether it be
internally or
externally I want to address one other
component of um an earlier discussion
which was relative to where the
nutrients come from we know that bottom
sediments and lakes represent the
activities or Legacy activities of the
uh landscape in the past and uh we have
no control over things that have
happened in the past however we do uh
reap the the uh consequences of those
activities from the past and what we're
seeing now is uh a buildup of nutrients
that are either have occurred over time
and are being contributed uh currently
in in the current state um we can't
control temperature your question was an
excellent one we do know that water
temperatures are increasing in our
surface waters around the state but we
can control the amount of nutrients that
are entering either from external
sources you're
welcome anyone else representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um I'll ask the same qu uh
your interpretation of the same question
I asked representative Rome on uh you
know on section four or um the new
section four of the um you
know what this line line 19 and 20 um
you know it says the department is
directed to reduce control and prevent
the nutrient inputs causing C bacteria
so to me like that's super broad but
then it's super restricts it and says
education um and education and
engagement as well as you know the the
thing we're talking about now the you
know treating the likes so I like your
interpretation of like how did um what
does you know the the headline in
subsection four cover and then what does
it mean to work with for example the
Lake Associations or um or others to
provide sort of comprehensive
reduction that's a pretty large question
I appreciate it thank you very much
um the this the proposal as written uh
the way we understand it uh is expanding
the current uh clean Lakes program such
that we could address cob bacteria
blooms directly calling them amount
directly um as a problem and and
recognizing as a problem and setting a
framework by which nutrients become the
focus to reduce the causes of C bacteria
blooms which as i' mentioned is the one
thing we actually have the ability to
control um personally I think there's
there's additional work to be done in
RSA 47 itself for a variety of reasons
it's a it's a statute that has been
built upon over time I I don't think
this would be the last time you would
see a request to make changes to RSA 47
but this is a starting point and uh
places a spotlight on its uh focus on
cob bacteria blooms and expanding it
Beyond uh the management of invasive
aquatic species and I I really think
that Lake management includes a holistic
Lakes
absolutely yeah so um you know I ALS was
thinking of when that question was first
asked to representative brang um we have
a lot of programs already within our
group and within the Watershed Bureau
that are focused on that external load
reduction um there are funding sources
available as well through the federal
clean water srf program and so over the
years we have been focused on the very
hyper local level of doing soak up the
rain projects with one of our programs
to educate Lake owners um how to just
manage their own runoff to reduce
nutrient pollution then we start getting
up higher and we have funding through
the federal um sources to implement
larger Watershed projects that are
really geared towards these best
management practices and so we are
already doing that um and then in the
cyanobacteria mitigation fund the recent
rules really establish two Pathways if
you're going to be doing an external
load Reduction Program or project and
then that internal and what I quick
learned when I took took on this role is
calls come into to Dave all summer of
how do we fix the problem we've got
cyanobacteria and we haven't had this
clear pathway and that's really a lot of
what this new legislation establishes is
how do we work with somebody who has or
in Watershed Association that has spent
the time to reduce their external
nutrient loads they've done the sediment
sampling as representative rang
mentioned they know there's an internal
problem
and so that's sort of where things have
stopped because we don't have clear
Authority we are jamming a square peg in
a round hole with permitting these types
of projects and so this really helps
open the door of the now what can we do
um and it gives us that ability to be
engaged in that process very early on
with these associations whom we likely
have already been working on to reduce
all their external loads over time so as
Dave mentioned it's a very complex
project it's not one size fits every
Lake and the department with the
programs we already have in place are
very involved with these associations
from the get-go and so we're not getting
to in Lake treatment lightly there's a
lot of work that goes in there and it's
not applicable to every water body
either um and so having this ability
having the ability to permit a project
puts us at the table with this and to be
able to make decisions that are
appropriate that are good for the water
quality good for the water body and that
representative
Kelly thank you um and thank you for
testifying today I'm just wondering if
you could expand a little bit about the
health impacts on on humans um I know we
um I guess the you know is it just as
simple as saying stay out of the water
and then that's the only you know health
impact that we could have on on
populations living there or is it are
there you know chronic conditions from
exposure
um that could
be C you know the the local population
could
see yeah thank you very much I
appreciate your question
um the the simple answer to your
question that we try to strive to tell
people is uh when in doubt stay out so
uh that's a very consistent message that
resonates with a lot of people so we ask
them to uh do this sort of self-risk
assessment when they're uh standing at
the shore of of a water body deciding
whether they want to recreate in it
whether it be swimming fishing paddling
um what have you uh the the real answer
to your question is the the toxicity of
cyob bacteria is real um it's not
something that uh is is meant to scare
people uh the effects are real they
range from short-term acute symptoms to
gastrointestinal discomfort um but they
can they serve as a neurotoxin so they
can be very severe and we've seen deaths
of dogs um in the state of New Hampshire
across the the country um some of the
work that we've shown in our cyob
bacteria plan about 50% to 2third of the
samples that we tested from 2022 had
detectable levels of cyanotoxins in them
risk any other
questions I have one additional uh this
is specifically this bill specifically
is for
in inl additions Pro it's an inl program
has nothing to do with well it has it
has it has nothing to do with septic
systems uh if there is something else
around septic systems around Lakes my
concern is that I don't want to see
this as the camel's nose in the
tent for to you as as I want to see this
bill uh become
a a method of controlling the septic
tank on the top of the mountain when
that's 100 miles away from the lakes
that type of thing so is
there you is this what exactly this is
only about the Alum you can add to the
to the water right is that what the this
bill is for or is or you feel as there's
there is pressure to be able or there
you now can go and say well this is also
we uh we when we get involved with the
watershed management plan maybe this
gives us a chance to take care of all of
those septic tanks out there even though
they're nowhere near a
lake I focus on lakes I'm our assistant
division director Mr deers who also has
oversight of some of the inl I me I mean
you're let him answer this question okay
okay and then I'll sit back down to
answer any of the questions they have
okay
you may it please the committee my uh
name is Ted deers I'm the assistant
director of The Water Division at the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services uh and I'm I'd
love to answer that question
Mr sh uh the fact of the matter is is
that this the way we view this and I
think the way that this legislation is
written is it it is coordinating
legislation the same way that the Clean
Water Act clean water program clean
Lakes program sorry is coordinating
legislation for aquatic invasives it
basically when it comes to things like
nutrients it's saying okay if we have a
problem there's lots of different
programs at Dees currently which can be
brought to bear to fix this program
without expanding The Authority
specifically for
cyanobacteria so if you look I think if
you read carefully this legislation it
truly is coordinating identifying that
there's a single place where if you have
this problem there's a group of people
we have funding through the general fund
for certain positions we have funding
through other programs that are coming
in that fund this work there's the clean
or the uh the the the Lakes uh loan
program the cyanobacteria loan and grant
program that was created all of these
things kind of come together as part of
this legislation in no way do we see and
and certainly I don't believe that this
Administration would support an
expansion of regulatory Authority uh on
uh by virtue of this particular program
this is a program dedicated and that's
why I think where you see some of the
words that I think representative Darby
brought to bear is that it is focused on
science it is focused on the monitoring
and then it's focused on the
coordination so yes inlay treatments the
reason why there's some focus on that is
because it's a doughnut hole a little
bit in currently the way we do things
we're trying to piece it together to be
able to do this this makes a clear
pathway for that particular practice
that it currently is a muddled uh
pathway so but I think to get right at
the the the qu the question is is that
uh again our Administration would not
support an expansion of author Authority
that would allow the kinds of things
that you're suggesting um might might
happen and and I I again we have lots of
other authorities that you all oversee
quite capably related to our septic
system regulations our Shoreland
regulations our Wetland regulations if
there was an expansion of authority that
would be coming to you thank any other
questions by members of the
committee if not will you fill out a c
please
much uh this
Andrea uh
Lakes good morning uh chair and Zulo and
members of the committee I'm Andrea
lamro president of New Hampshire lakes
and I am here to support this bill uh
New Hampshire Lakes we're a Statewide
nonprofit organization we represent
about 275 Lake Associations um and I
know you've heard from many of them um
signing in in in support of this bill um
you have heard from the experts um and I
would say congratulations um I learned
about internal loading when I was in
graduate school um so you um may have a
graduate degree going here um but we
support this bill for all the reasons uh
that Aon and Dave and representative
Rong um shared with you we New Hampshire
Lakes are based uh a group based in
science and we have full trust in Dees
that they are going to stick to um
science and and not um let this you know
do overreach and get into other topics
this is is um sorely needed here in New
Hampshire cyano bacteria uh we need a
better way a more streamlined way a more
direct path to managing it in the lake
when and where it's appropriate uh we
have a lot of Lake
Associations um and I we work in New
Hampshire Lakes we work with Lake
Associations to reduce the amount of
nutrients coming off the landscape we
run our lak smart Lake friendly Living
Program and there's a lot of work being
done um in a lot of communities to
reduce the external loading um and
sometimes you know that's not enough um
and so again we have full trust in Dees
to come up with a process um that is is
straightforward efficient and
scientifically appropriate to deal with
uh these blooms that we all as as humans
on the land on the landscape have um
contributed to so I urge you to support
this bill and um would happy to be happy
to answer any
questions is there any questions by
committee see none thank you very much
great thank
you have no more pink cards I want to
say one thing uh this uh bill is
probably is coming forth based on the
plan that was put together uh on cyano
bacteria at the behest of this committee
so uh we you know it it is so we're the
we're actually the Foster of it and they
did a fantastic job putting that plan
together and I by the way I think I sent
it out to everybody but I think uh
probably representative rung and myself
are the only ones who've read
it oh you too thank you very
much
am thank you uh yes pleas pass the
amendment out and uh please put it
away do not do but please bring enough
exact that raed issu with amendments
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
amendment oh okay I think the clerk
needs an amendment before me okay you
have your Amendment okay all right
that's that's it okay I will close the
hearing
on House Bill
[Music]
wow I don't I don't think I can hold it
down right
now one has OTP
onl that's the one that's the one with
the cyanide in it oh
cyanobacteria
pie
oh
e
can you fill out a pink
please
call the hearing to call a hearing to
128n uh representative Duty the floor is
yours thank you very much
representative um my name is Sher Duty I
represent Hillsboro district 6 uh
Nashville ward 3 um and I also uh chair
the Nashville Conservation Commission
um so this bill came about from my
experience on the nashille Conservation
Commission as an urban Conservation
Commission we are asked to rule on tree
cutting in Wetland buffers many of the
homes in NASA were built in the 50s 60s
and 7s before Wetland ordinances were
tightened up in some cases we have seen
houses built in what is now considered a
wetland
buffer knowledgeable and responsible
home homeowners know that before any
tree cutting can occur in a wetland
buffer they need to submit an
application to their Conservation
Commission and have a determination made
as to how many and where trees can be
cut one problem is that as homes are
sold the next owner doesn't necessarily
know about these ordinances in most
cases when they call a responsible Tree
Service Company they are notified of a
possible problem and and directed to
call their municipal office for guidance
prior to trees being cut in other cases
the Tree Service Company Logging company
or other tree cutting entity withhold
this information and protect themselves
by placing in the fine print a notice
that the landowner is responsible for
all P permitting as we all know it is
rare for any of us to go over a contract
line by line especially the fine print
in urban settings when illegal cutting
occurs someone usually makes an inquiry
to the city or registers a complaint
this happens at the time of tree cutting
so the damage to the Wetland is done and
the landowner is on the hook for
mitigation costs HB 1208 addresses this
problem by mandating that any tree
cutting service logger or other entity
cutting trees must ask the landowner to
see the approval permits and place
copies in their files if the homeowner
doesn't have paperwork indicating an
approval to cut the tree cutting service
logger or entity must advise the
landowner on the process of
obtaining uh of obtaining the permits in
the qu in the case of a questionable cut
and they can't provide copies of the
permits they could be fined per uh RSA
482 d a uh colon 13 the Nashville
Conservation Commission has explored
other ways to protect Wetlands but none
have been feasible Realtors are not
interested in being responsible for
informing potential buyers that there
could be restrictions on the land and
markers don't work since they are costly
um require uh surveyors and boundaries
committee Mr representative
Darby thank you Mr chair I thank you
representative for taking my question is
there a specific case in nashille that
comes to mind that sort of um make you
point uh yes there were actually uh I've
been on the Conservation Commission
since I believe 2013 or
2014 um there's been three that I've
known of one I'm trying to think three
or four um one when I came on there was
one during my time um and uh we we just
mitigated one um at this past session
okay uh and that's basically the reason
why this came out uh this was the first
homeowner um who was uh
I mean it was obvious that he was
unaware that there were any
regulations um a couple of the trees
were cut within a foot 2 feet um of um
Salmon Brook which is I think a third
order stream okay so so I mean anybody
in the tree cutting business would have
known I mean I mean it was so obvious
that I think he took down 20 or 22 trees
and all of them were in the Wetland
buffer um so the home home owner was
really unaware of the ordinances um
ended up working with us ended up giving
me the name of the company and um and
that's when we went through um the city
I went through the city to say I mean
how could this be done and that's when I
found out that um these tree cutting
services will come in um they charge the
homeowner they sell the wood uh they
already know before they cut it how much
they're going to get on the market for
it and they protect them M themselves
because in the fine print it says that
they're not
responsible um you know for any
permitting and that's responsible the
landowner in the one previous case that
I can remember um it was a family that
had just moved in from
Massachusetts uh having sold a house
that abutted conservation land they had
a logger come in and take down I don't
know 20 or 30 trees in the Wetland
buffer
um they couldn't remember the name of
the logger um they couldn't remember I
mean I guess the truck just came out one
day and cut down 20 trees and they
didn't know who it was um and um you
know they were very uncooperative and it
was clear in that case um because of
where the cutting was is is that the
Hope was that they could improve um they
had a small backyard and they wanted to
enlarge the backyard so they had the
or followup thank you Mr chair and and
did you say the homeowner is on the hook
for uh fines related to that in these
cases uh not necessarily fines but for
mitigation so so for example when you
you know I mean per the wet Wetland
ordinances in Nashua um if you uh
illegally remove uh cut trees or
illegally remove um uh Native shrubs or
whatever from a wetland buffer then uh
you uh have to mitigate that um and
mitigating it you know so it comes uh
before the Conservation Commission and
then we make a determination of what the
homeowner you know has to do um in this
case uh it would you know I mean he was
he was very concerned about it but I
believe see I believe the um he was
charged $4,500 to take on the trees and
I believe we've estimated his mitigation
cost at possibly another
$5,000 so I mean you know depending on
how extensive it is it can be you know
really substantial
yeah representative
donelly thank you Mr thank you the chair
and thank you for taking my question um
do you know if there is an education
program for tree cutting services so
they can actually go in and and
understand when they're evaluating um a
project if there is Wetlands if there's
not Wetlands is there any and I know DS
here for this question maybe but is
there any programs for them to be taking
so that they're aware of this ahead of
time I I hate to make assumptions on
whether they know or not know yeah well
you know you have the uh you you have
organizations um that they can they can
belong to if they choose so I mean BAS
basically what we see is you have
reputable arborus who belong to what is
it the um New Hampshire tree Association
I I believe that's the name of it they
have ongoing um uh you know education
courses on on all kinds of things um so
yeah what what we have you know and it
was interesting in in this last case I
went up on their website and you need so
you go on an arur website and and you
know you you can see that they're a
certified Arborist okay and you say okay
well you know they probably know what
they're doing in this last case they had
links to what a certified Arborist does
okay or is but there was nothing on the
site that led you to believe that
anybody on their staff was a certified
Arborist and I believe in the in the
state I mean you know I mean I can go
out and cut trees I could take my
chainsaw put a sign on a truck and go
out and cut trees as far as I know so um
they can be educated uh you know this
the the last company has been B in
business for a long time very hard for
me to believe that a company that's been
cutting trees for a long time doesn't
know that when the tree is a foot from
the water's edge
that there might be a problem so so we
you know it's it's really the
Rogue um it's it's really a a way I mean
what it's two things you have the
homeowners who really don't care they
just want to get the trees cut down and
you know and they don't care so they
hire anybody or everybody but you really
have you know caring unsuspecting I mean
it would just be like any of us here if
I hired somebody to put in an
you know a new furnace for me and you're
hiring a responsible company that's been
in business for a long time you know you
don't expect to find out you know 6
months later that you didn't get a
permit I mean how would you know you
know I mean you expect and and we've had
situations where a homeowner has wanted
to take wanted to replace a shed uh in a
wetland buffer and um Hills fair was it
is it Hills fairy Reeds fairy so Reeds
fairy came out looked at it and said you
know you should contact your
Conservation Commission you're in a
wetland buffer and um and you may need
an approval so I mean that's what
reputable companies do but you know a
lot of times the company looks reputable
especially in this business they have
trucks they have cranes they look you
know um but this the homeowner gets
blindsided and I don't think it's a
stretch to ask a um a reputable business
um to just ask the homeowner have you
received do you you know do you know
that this could Wetland rules could
apply so why don't you call your
municipality and just check and we've
had situations where that's happened and
the um department manager has called me
and said you know Sherry I mean I think
it's an issue where it's borderline I
don't think we have to do anything about
it I feel comfortable with the homeowner
going ahead with this and we say fine
other times we get an application you
know and that's that's the other thing
you know I mean they have to pay for the
application so people who follow the
rules you know will come to us and then
we'll do a site visit and then we'll
negotiate because we recognize you know
I mean you know we recognize they bought
a house you know they have some um I you
know ideas about it and so we negotiate
and say okay well if you do this we
would like you to plant some native
plants here you know and work with them
to you know maintain the habitat and the
so any other question representative
harb thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I appreciate
your comments regarding
owners but I read the um bill and I
don't see anywhere in the bill that
exempts the owner from the mitigation
requirements that it gives him a
whitewash like as long as he hires
somebody then he doesn't have to worry
about it it just says the person cutting
or doing the work needs to verify the
permitting but it it's not an exemption
for the owner for that
mitigation am I missing
something well you mean that there might
be mate right I mean the
homeowner uh may
still the Conservation Commission may
still ask the
homeowner um at that point probably not
mitigation because you're talking about
two different things so we see this is
this usually comes to us as code
enforcement the trees have already been
cut down the damage has been done it's
code enforcement so now the Conservation
Commission can can really say to them
you know you need to do this okay on the
other hand people who follow the rules
uh provide us with an application so
that's before and they say Okay I want
to cut down six trees because I'm
getting older this was the case and um
I'm you know I don't always want to uh
have uh pine needles and pine limbs to
you know to rake up so we go out we look
at the property and we'd say to them
okay we we can't allow you to cut down
six eight trees but we can have you cut
down two or three trees that might be
leaning against the house they they
might be a danger you know at that point
we make a suggestion you know what you
might want to do um you know for
drainage issues into the the Wetland you
know you might want to plant some bushes
or something like that but they're not
it's not mandated at that point um
because they've come to us prior they've
gotten our approval and you know we
really do try we really do try to work
with people you know I mean that that's
the whole issue
with you know with the conflict between
Wildlife the environment and you know um
areas
repres
representative wolf then representative
Derby I don't
see that you should be taking this off
of the homeowner the homeowner is the
one that you
have enforcement against that should
have done everything in accordance with
your rules in the city of nashor for
protecting the
wetlands um you know and if somebody
builds a ship in there it's not the guy
that built the shed that even didn't
truck it that sold it out of the lot at
uh Home Depot it's the homeowner and I
don't see anything in here that's that's
um going after the homeowner who's
benefiting from The
Cutting oh representative the the whole
point is prevention okay so you you
can't prevent an a problem if you're not
educated about it okay and what we're
saying I mean especially in nashwa I
mean I don't know how many homes we have
sold in a month but probably close to
well maybe not like this week but I mean
at the at the height of the Season you
know you're probably talking a couple
thousand or maybe a thousand homes a
month that that turn over okay and uh
and people don't know so all this bill
does is force um a tree cutting service
to educate the
homeowner that a um permit may be
required if the homeowner says I don't
want to get a permit cut the trees down
and I'll take my chances they can still
do that but then it becomes code
enforcement and now they've got a
problem okay so so this is really just
notifying a
homeowner that they need this permit it
would be no different than let's say If
you hired a construction company and
they said okay before I can build this
uh you need a building permit and you
say oh okay I didn't know that I just
wanted to you know change the windows in
my garage or something no you need a
building permit okay do you get it or do
I get it no you have to get it that
that's basically all it
so it's the homeowner's responsibility
then because they're going to have to
get a building permit if they hire
somebody that puts the windows in
without a permit do you have to notify
should we put a law in place that
notifies all the window installers that
they have to get a
permit well I would assume that when
you're hiring somebody
reputable okay that that they would
uh you know and all we're trying to do
is say
um you know
reputable this should be absolutely no
problem for a reputable tree cutting
service or
entity it should be no problem at all
okay I mean rather you know I mean they
expect a check I I just expect a copy of
the permit okay so it's no problem um
and for those that want to you know that
are not reputable and find it profitable
to cut trees in a in a wetland um you
price representative uh Derby thank you
Mr chair um thank you for taking my
question so I can I can see the
conundrum which is that um the you know
the homeowner sometimes they don't they
don't know right they just don't know um
and um people that cut a lot of trees do
do know I'm almost done I'm one more
second I'm I'm almost at the question um
so but the the problem is that I that
I'm trying to ask about is that the
homeowner um this puts the burden on
getting the permit on the entity cutting
the trees no that's that's the way I'm
reading it in four 4 A
um shall the agent or contractor shall
verify compliance with all permitting
documents yeah all they have to do is
ask that they are not responsible for
the permitting they are responsible for
asking the
homeowner did you this is a questionable
situation you know have you gotten the
approval of your municipality your town
or your Conservation Commission and if
so can you show me the letter that I can
copy
they they don't have to do the
permitting at all if
you
yeah so all they have to do is get the
permit they have to see the permit and
file yeah so you know so prior to any
person or entity commencing Timber
harvesting operations in Wetlands as
described in paragraphs one or two okay
including an agent of or contractor for
a landowner the person or entity shall
verify compliance with all permitting so
all they have to do is verify
compliance it's still the land owner the
permits I mean if you find that to be um
confusing you know we can tighten it up
but the intent was that the
responsibility is the
landowner and the entity's only
responsibility is to verify you know in
you know I mean if I'm having a tree cut
in my front yard that's no big deal but
I mean you know if you're walking into
an area and your shoes are getting
wet you know or you're you know cutting
cting a tree 2 feet or a foot from the
stream most tree cutting services who
are
experienced understand that that could
issue is there any other question
representative run thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my
question to my understanding it seems
like it is common practice for
contractors that are doing work near um
a Wetlands or a water body for instance
if someone is having a dock replaced or
a deck replaced near water that the
contractor is aware that permits are
required so is that to me I mean do you
find it unusual that someone doing work
near a regulated area would be aware
like they I think they would ask the
tree cutter would say oh you know you
need to get a permit for this sometimes
they offer to get the permit perit for
the homeowner question is I'm sorry so
do you find that unusual that they um
that the person doing the work wouldn't
required It's Not Unusual for
um an how do I want to say this if
you're a
reputable um tree cutting service you
have arborus on staff or whatever um
it's not problem they they would do that
but you know trust me I mean they have
to be out there and I assume it you know
in rural areas it probably happens a lot
but I mean and they're not I I would
call them a fly by night but they're not
a a fly by night I mean that's their
business you know I mean they I mean
they see an area of pristine trees along
a wetland that you know haven't been
touched for I don't know 50 75 100 years
and you know they might be what 30 40
feet tall nice and straight they don't
have any dings in them from golf balls
or frisbees or anything else and you
know there's a profit motive in there
let me cut them down and uh sell them on
the on the market um so you know so you
are going to have companies um that know
what the regulations are know what they
should be doing but the profit motive
overcomes it and th and those are the
Bad actors that were trying to um you
know
penalize or a followup okay so with this
bill though when you're talking about
the Bad actors then this bill because of
the reporting requirements and the
records retention uh component would
provide that accountability okay thank
youil for
question yes so I just um representative
Duty thank you for taking my question
and for coming in today um would you say
that if a waiver is in the contract in
other words if the person is I'm I have
a tree service and Suzanne's Tree
Service um has this thing where at the
bottom there's a disclaimer that says if
you don't have the permits or if you
wait a
minute it's up to you you're 100% liable
then they would know that there's
liability for taking down trees in the
Wetland area so for me it's like we're
talking about do people does the tree
service know what they're
doing to me if if you sign a contract
and you write somebody a check and that
contract says that you're responsible
for picking up any permits that are
necessary and they just let go of it at
that that you're the one who's
responsible that they know there is a
respons responsibility and someone has
to Bear it so in other words we can't
say that a tree service wouldn't know if
then fact they are putting it in their
contract that they know that you should
have these permanence do that com
out
yeah well you know I mean that that's an
i another way to handle the issue um
they have a disclaimer that says we are
not responsible but you know I mean you
could modify it to say that all quotes I
mean because they have to quote you know
I mean you have to have a paper quote
when you ask somebody to come in and you
know so you could also do something
where all quotes at the bottom you know
must have a
notification that permits may be um
required before the work can be done uh
and then you know please contact us
please contact your municipality or
something like that so that could be an
another way of handling it um you know
although a lot of the Bad actors what
they basically and you know um this is
why homeowners will take them up on it
they'll come in and they'll say we'll
cut the trees for
nothing okay so I mean there's not even
a
quote in involved we'll cut the trees
for nothing because they know that that
they can sell it and the homeown owner
is thinking gee you know i' be nice to
be able to have more open space you know
and en large my backyard and then they
end up planting
grass you know and um non-native plants
uh in a wetland or on the Bo on the edge
of a wetland or in a wetland and that's
not what we
want thank you so much for
clarifying anyone else I I do have a
question myself what what uh what is
just the setback uh on your yeah um
let's see for uh Prime wet lens it's 75
ft and for critical wet lenss it's 40
and then you know then we have I think
20 ft for other wet lenss that are less
than I don't know less than three
between 3,000 and 9,000 square F feet or
something like
that but what for the for what we talk
about it would be either a 40 foot
40 foot or 75t and what was the size of
the
lot uh well I mean on this on this
specific one oh on this specific one I'm
going to say you
know maybe about 75 ft of Frontage along
Salmon Brook third order stream and the
size of the
lot pardon then the size of the lot I'm
just trying to get an idea of how much
of the lot was was actually being used
by the Wetland by the Wetland
set yeah uh well actually so in in this
case they had a formal
backyard um with a lawn and a fence and
a and a wall a and part of
um half what was it I think about about
half of their backyard was actually in
the Wetland okay and that was in place
well yeah that so that was illegally
done and then from the stone wall uh to
the third order
stream um I would say in one case it was
pretty close like 10 ft um you know so
they had the formal backyard that they
used and then the natural natural part
of it and I think in one case um there
was 75t of buffer that was still their
yard and that was natural that they
wanted to convert to Grass to enlarge
the yard um but actually where most of
the trees were cut down um they um they
weren't going
to put anything in that area they just
wanted to improve their
view okay good for a followup yes uh the
uh
uh the these uh setbacks were
established after the the houses were
built well you know I I assume so so uh
I think what conservation commissions
came in in what the
60s and then and I don't you probably
know this better than me I don't know
when a lot of the Wetland regulations
came in but you know the house was
probably built in Theif I'm looking at
that neighborhood probably the 50s or
the 60s okay thank you yeah
thank you anyone else for a
question representative
wolf how many cases do you have of this
type in a
year uh not in a year no I like I say
I've been on the Conservation Commission
so we've had uh three since I've been
there so three in the last 10
years okay anyone else seeing none no
representative Kelly under the white
sorry um so I'm trying to wrap my head
around a lot of this because you know
the there are a lot of restrictions in
in 227 about you know surrounding
wetlands and but it seems like there is
a bit of a loophole um that I see that
it seems like you're trying to to get
and that's that the larger operations
that require an intent to cut require
the person cutting to sign off on a
document that says that they understand
the rules of cutting in New State of New
Hampshire but what we don't have is for
those who don't require intent to cut
anybody less than 10,000 board feet is
not required to make that same
distinction so you have smaller groups
coming in who are cutting less than
10,000 board feet and then putting it on
the homeowner so um is that that am I
clear that's the loophole that you're
looking to toct right thank you yeah and
you know I'm only talking about the
Nashville Conservation Commission I mean
you know um when I've I mean I think
this is an issue in other areas
uh of the State uh but I'm not privy to
that um you know and I think also in
rural areas it might be a little bit
more difficult I mean people may not
know what's going on and they don't um
you know they they don't report it
because it's rural I mean unless you're
driving by and you're seeing a a crane
and and you know that that's a river
undetected any other questions questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
it uh Steve
Lance chairperson Rula and members of
the committee uh my name is Steven
Sherman I am the chief of the New
Hampshire Forest Protection Bureau which
is part of the division of forest and
lands I would like to make the following
comments on behalf of the director of
the division of forest and lands Patrick
Hackley um there is also written copies
of these
statements uh thank you for the
opportunity to testify on House Bill 128
relative to permitting requirements
before Timber harvesting operations and
Wetland while our agency is tasked with
enforcing the laws passed by the
legislature we find the bill to be
unworkable on several levels and
therefore we are opposed to its passage
the division of forest and lands is
charged with the execution of all
matters pertaining to forestry Forest
management and Forest lands within the
jurisdiction of the state one of our key
responsibilities is to protect our
natural resources for the benefit of the
state's citizens
visitors and Forest industry in
cooperation with the Department of
Environmental Services our forest
Protection Bureau forest rangers
enforced the provisions of RSA 227 j6
operations in
Wetlands the Bill's proposed paragraph
four implies that municipalities May
impose their own Wetland ordinances
conflicts with the state's jurisdiction
under RSA
482 a colon 3 paragraph 5 which
authorizes the Department of
Environmental Services and the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources to regulate and enforce
forestry related Wetland permitting
activities any persons who have complied
with the notice of intent to cut wood
requirements under RSA
7910 and who have filed an appropriate
notification of forest management
activities having minimum Wetlands imp
impa with Dees and our agency have
satisfied the permitting requirements
for minimum impact
activities the bill is also unclear as
to what entity is responsible for
enforcing the
provisions RSA 227 J2 paragraph 1A
states that the director and the
director's authorized agents shall be
the primary enforcement agency for this
chapter while the state is not obligated
to enforce town ordinances our
division's forest Protection Bureau will
likely be called upon as few towns have
the staff to conduct inspections nor
have the statutory authority to enter on
to private land this would stretch our
staff resources and create confusion
within the forestry and landowner
communities currently when a landowner
files their intent to cut and Forestry
notification for minimum Wetlands impact
with Dees and our agency they typically
can proceed with their management plans
within a 15-day time period this bill
proposes that a landowner would need to
have all state Municipal Wetland permits
in hand before commencing their
operation potentially causing an
administrative delay and adding another
impediment to practicing forestry for
these reasons we are opposed to House
Bill
128 thank you for the opportunity to
testify um if I can provide any
know any questions but members of the
committee representative Kelly then
representative
run run then representative Kelly thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm a little confused by the
letter because can a homeowner cut down
two three eight trees without uh having
to file an intent to cut
form yes um so with with this when you
look at the 227 J laws the their
intention is for forestry um and and
while sometimes it does go into the
development side of it uh really we have
two different things going on um so can
a landowner go in and cut six trees uh
without filing an intent to cut they can
and it was mentioned the exemption of
10,000 board fees and 20 cord as well as
an exemption to be able to cut trees
that are within Striking Distance of
your house and that's for the protection
of people's personal property that if
trees are mature and they may fall down
PE land owners can go in and cut those
trees so that or have those trees cut so
they don't fall on their house follow up
Mr chair follow so with that answer so
you recognize that this bill is really
address ing people who are exempt from
the laws and regulations which fall
under your per purview am I correct in
that I think after listening to
testimony the intent of the bill is is
for that however with the bill being
under 227 j6 and addressing the intent
to cut laws it's adding another level
for any timber Harvest within the state
of New Hampshire okay just one more
so if it was in another area of Statute
there you you wouldn't have as much
concern
I I guess uh I I don't know where it
would end up um I mean if it was placed
somewhere else and was specific more to
development um I I think that might be
something uh that could could be looked
at uh I we would as an agency to see
what that looks like um but being under
the forestry laws as it's written it
would pertain to every Timber harvest in
the state and um I it doesn't sound like
that would be the intent okay thank
Kelly representative rung touched on my
question so I'm not sure how much
there's left to ask but I guess the I'm
just wondering if you you sounds like
you heard the previous speaker's
testimony and and you recognize that
there's seems to be a little bit of a a
loophole or some type of issue where the
on these smaller Cuts where we're less
than the pa7 you know requirements that
the somebody's signing off saying that
they understand that they you have to
follow best management practices and and
all the other laws that we've laid out
so it does seem like there like I don't
know if you have any recommendations on
you know on these smaller cutting
practices like you know these uh these
smaller you know if there's anything you
would recommend just that' be my only
question I I think as an agency we may
come up with recommendations but I'm not
any any other
questions representative Bale thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I just wanted to um so this
being under a certain section in the law
is there another place that where we
would be able to do
this where we can address the um problem
that we're trying to solve which is an
individual homeowner getting um a tree
service to come and then cutting in the
Wetland buffer zone leaving the
homeowner
to remediate and all of the costs that
are associated with
that I think consultation with uh the
Department of Environmental Services may
be worthwhile um I know they have their
Shand protection laws so they they do
more of the Wetland um they they have
jurisdiction more over development in
Wetlands than than we do Under the
forestry end uh so possibly under uh one
of de's laws and I'm not familiar with
all the laws that uh give towns
authorization for ordinances or
conservation commissions there may be
somewhere there as well um but I think
we need to be careful on on making the
distinction between homeowner
development and Timber
harvesting uh as as a whole throughout
the state I think there's a a
made representative Kelly for a second
time thank you thank you chairman I
thought of a better question so um I'm
not sure how familiar you are with 227
j9 um the penalties and and cutting on
near Waterway So speaking specifically
like just so that we all have an idea
speaking specifically about the case
that was described with the 22 trees in
nsha um under you know the the rules do
say that they can't cut more than 50%
basal area with you know within 150 ft
of a wetland so my question is and it
says that the town if they if they
notify your department first can pursue
a misdemeanor penalty um um and my so my
question is you know in that case you
know what what responsibility does your
department have to to to check you know
that they're you know that they're
meeting that 50% basal area requirement
you know with if it's just a single lot
with a little bit of Frontage on a a
stream multi-park question um so 227 j9
uh is the basil area law which does
restrict the um amount of wood that can
be cut with in uh the area close to
water B so it pertains to lakes rivers
streams um you you can in fact cut
inside of a wetland um during certain
times of the year and taking the minimum
impact notification and adhering to the
best management for Forest practices um
so as far as
um this situation where so we we get
notified as an agency anytime an intent
to cut is filed as well as we get copies
of the uh minimum impact notifications
or they call them SPN now statutory
permit by notification uh through Dees
so we get copies of those um we have 10
forest rangers currently covering the
state and they go out and inspect the
timber Harvest and if they see an issue
where somebody has exceeded the 50%
basil area then they talk to the land
owner in some cases they There are rules
that allow them to exceed that they have
uh 180 days to convert the land so they
they could convert the area that they
cut and make it into yard or field uh
because again that's the buffer between
a water body or lake and stream
um however when you get into larger
water bodies you run into Shoreland
protection ction with Department of
Environmental Services and they have to
comply with those regulations as well um
so in this case with 10 12 trees that
don't meet the exemption or or meet the
exemption for an intent to cut to be
filed we as an agency wouldn't know that
was happening uh because we wouldn't
receive the intent to cut if we received
a complaint we would go and look um and
if it falls under a town ordinance then
we would that that would be up for the
town to enforce but we would have to
take the time to go out and inspect it
that anyone else seeing no one thank you
time Jason
Association
so
Flor is yours good good morning and and
thank you all for your
Indulgence I think I'm the last speaker
before lunch so this is always a
dangerous and perilous area to be but
I'll try to be brief um for the record
I'm Jason stock executive director of
the New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association and um I've come here to
provide you some information and we are
speaking in opposition to this bill and
I wanted to kind of point out a couple
things you've already touched on this
this affects more than just a homeowner
cutting a few trees in their
backyard as as drafted it's any person
or entity Timber harvesting so this
includes commercial Timber harvesting
and and that's why I'm here today is
this this affects affects our our
constituency
um we represent land owners we represent
loggers Foresters and and wood using
entities our members own own and or
manage over a million Acres across the
state and that many of that acerage has
waterfront property has I would dare say
most of it has Wetlands we live in a
very humid climate and there's Wetlands
everywhere um and as a result the state
of New Hampshire has has laws governing
this and in the harvesting of trees and
in fact the state of New Hampshire has
several layers of laws regarding this
you heard from uh Mr Sherman earlier who
was the division of forest and lands
he's he is law enforcement for the
forestry laws but his laws also include
wetlands and then we of course have the
Department of Environmental Services and
they also have enforcement Authority
they can enforce they can enforce
Wetlands law
laws um the the a couple things and and
I think one of the elements of this bill
that kind of concerns us is you're
mixing some apples and oranges here just
the mere fact that the situation that
prompted this bill was a homeowner
cutting some
trees on their property that were in a
wetland or adjacent to a piece of water
um it you know and they they cut these
trees they had a it appears they had a
contract they had signed a contract and
like it or not there was language in
that contract um that said You landowner
are responsible for this landowner come
to find out land owners the trees
weren't supposed to be cut um I it it
sounds like they were in a buffer area
of some type and landowner is not happy
about that and said
I didn't like the you know I didn't see
the fine
print they should we should we should
address this and and require a a
notification process you know let's
codify that in law well we have I heard
three per 10 years instances of this
there are over 2,000 Timber sales a year
in the state of New Hampshire that occur
these requirements would affect in
essence almost every one of those unless
you're on a very unique site that's
really high and dry and you know there's
no there are no Wetlands so as drafted
that's a that's a piece that that that
concerns us um those commercial Timber
sales come in all shapes and sizes um
there are instances where a landowner
calls a logger directly and says hey
Chopper Bob I'd like you to cut some
trees down I've got some sick sick trees
on the back 40 let's cut those down
Chopper Bob and the
landowner um figure you know they they
fil the intent to cut they do the they
do what's needed to be done um to get
their permits and Chopper bob cuts it
there are also instances where a
landowner may have a a
Forester Forester will take part of take
care of some of that administrative work
as well they will kind of they're an
agent of that land owner they'll do the
paperwork there are Foresters that will
say look I'll give you the prescription
I'll tell Chopper Bob which trees to cut
but you landowner it's on you to do the
permitting or it's on Chopper Bob to do
the permitting but I'll I'll give you
the prescription and I'll tell you how
to you know what you want to achieve
with this property I'll I'll do that
then there's also what's called cut and
yard
operations land owner and a
Forester um decide to have a Timber sale
they call Chopper up and they say
Chopper bob cut all the trees out there
with a slash of blue paint on it bring
them to the log landing and we'll Market
we're going to market the wood you just
load the trucks as they show up so as
drafted here it's the person that cuts
the trees it's it presumes that that
person is kind of the the the the entity
that's doing this and that's not always
the case and so that's that's also
another problem is that you've got a a
bill that presumes one that these
business Arrangements happen kind of in
a static set process and that's not the
case there's they come in all shapes and
sizes on our little piece of property in
Tilton um I've had Foresters I've I have
a Consulting Forester that came in and I
just said I want you to set up the
prescription you mark the trees and in
this case I went to directly to the mill
I called The Sawmill up and I said will
you come in and and have the trees cut
they called Chopper Bob in this case
Adam mock out of Webster they called
addan and Addie addan is Sun cut the
trees sent him to the mill again these
come in all shapes and sizes Addie did
not do the permitting the Forester did
Sawmill didn't do the pering the
Forester did so again this bill presumes
that these are very linear um deals and
that's not always the case um the other
piece is that
um these as as we read it and and and Mr
Sherman testified to this there's a
question about Municipal ordinances and
how Municipal ordinances come into
effect if you look at the the RSA 674
colon 1 the very last
paragraph
um and and really it's the last sentence
of that last paragraph such these are
the duties of the planning board such
Powers should not include regulating
Timber harvesting operations that are
not part of a subdivision application or
a development subject to site plan
review so what this says and this has
actually been
challenged and um affirmed in in
Rockingham County Superior Court what it
says is if it's a commercial Timber sale
if it's if it's a if it's Timber
harvesting um not even commercial it
just says Timber harvesting um unless
it's site plan plan review or if it's a
project that was a
subdivision that that purview falls with
Dees they regulate that um and so again
when we read this there's a presumption
that all wood that's being cut that
there's some kind of Municipal ordinance
that may apply that is that is in fact
not the case um particularly on
Commercial Timber sales with respect to
the to to the um issue of you know well
what about those projects where uh an
intent to cut isn't filed so there are
exemptions if I go out back I I heat
with wood I hope many of you do as well
but if I go out back and cut a dozen
trees split it put it up and let it dry
out that's a and it's less than I
believe it's 20 qu 10 got get this right
20 cords thank you it's less than 20
cords I don't have to get a per I don't
don't have to file an intent to cut now
if I go out back and and there's a a
wetland area or there's an area out back
you know no intent to cut is filed uh Mr
Sherman he's not going to know he's not
going to police everyone in the state
that's cutting wood for their wood stove
so again to to to basically tell the
division of force and lands now if
there's any trees getting cut even on
these some of these personal
exemptions you now are going to be
responsible for for ensuring that
there's this paper chain of permit
notification process or
verification um I think is is part of
the re part of the some of the concern
that you're hearing in terms of
resources for the
state
um me just so there is a the the other
piece is education um we heard about
homeowners new homeowners not getting
educated nhtoa we run education programs
for loggers commercial loggers we have a
it's a voluntary certification program
to get to get certified as a logger you
take four core classes one of which is
Timber harvesting law we also have these
classes for municipal officials you will
be surprised that there are municipal
officials that not all of them and I get
it we're all volunteers I volunteer at
the local level not all of them know the
laws and so we'll have them for the for
the for municipal officials well as well
and provide information on Wetlands
basil area um all these regulations that
you we we've kind of touched on today so
there is a there is an education piece I
would I would put forth the idea that
perhaps in in some of these
municipalities maybe at the town office
or or you know or at the transfer
station which is always a hot spot for
discussion and information sharing is
you have some information there for
homeowners no you know there is
no rigid uh information conduit for
homeowners saying if you're going to be
cutting trees um for whatever reason you
know the in this case the city of nashwa
there are there are ordinances there are
setbacks please please call the concom
they'll be happy to happy to come out
and talk to you and consult with him but
again when I talk to the tree tree
services they'll say look we don't know
we we we don't we operate in so many
communities that you know for us to know
all the nuances of the local ordinances
in every Community we operate they said
moreover some of these subdivisions have
covenants on them or they'll have
conditions when the plan was reviewed or
the site plan was approved and they said
so for us to go in and go in and start
you know we just want to cut some trees
and make sure that person is happy with
their tree service for us to start
digging into some of these covenants and
some of these conditions on this the
original site plan to understand what
can and can't be
cut you know sure we can do it we can
hire and have an OnStaff attorney and
permitting expert but I don't think our
clients would be happy with our new tree
service fees so again that's why you'll
frequently see look if you want us to
cut trees if they're near your swimming
pool your house or on the edge of your
backyard you folks you figure it out
call your homeowners
association call you know call the town
call The Code Enforcement that's on you
know you're better suited to do that
than to have us come in and do that um
and then you know
lastly you know this was a this was a
contract issue and so you know we kind
of bring it back to the the core here
this was a contract issue you had a
contract that was signed um between a a
a service provider and a
homeowner and the homeowner wasn't happy
um and so again to try and legislate a
fix for such a contract I mean we could
go down the list um I know there are
folks on this committee that are in the
building business or do building you
know to so to legislate if if there's an
unhappy client there that says gez I
wish their quote included
mentioning cost overruns well let's pass
a bill that all quotes now need to
include a provision on cost overruns you
could start to see where you're heading
down this down this Rabbit Hole so again
I appreciate representative Duty's
efforts here I think I think a more
effective way and I've I did talk with
her before we F this was filed and but I
I think a more effective way to address
this is one of education and not
regulation or legislation in this case
and I think it's it's the homeowner
they're they're the members of the
homeowners association they're the
members that they are the folks that are
best equipped to go to the code
enforcement officer go to their
Association
Etc and get the in you know get what are
the restrictions here for my
backyard um with that I'll I'll I'll
conclude my testimony I'm happy to try
and answer any questions and uh thank
you for your Indulgence this
morning thank you is there any questions
by members of the committee
representative Kelly and representative
run thank you Mr chair um so my question
so I know I know I think I know what
half your answer is going to be but all
right the so the the you know the pa7
the intent to cut has a line where it
requires the Forester the person
conducting the cut to to sign off and
say I understand the rules I understand
the law so my question is you know what
would be the Fallout from just requiring
an intent to cut from anybody condu
conducting a cut on anyone else's
property so land owner would be would be
um Exempted but but then just require
saying that section 8 where you actually
break down what you're doing does isn't
required until you hit that 10,000 board
foot yeah great question so I have I
have a neighbor um an elderly neighbor
they have they have a wood stove they
call me up and say Jason you have some
strapping young Sons why don't you come
over and cut some firewood and I'll pay
them 10 bucks and buy some pizza for him
this afternoon and why don't you cut
some firewood on our property for my
wood stove um and so to require an
intent to cut for my young Sons to go
out and cut my neighbors's firewood for
their personal consum consumption um I
think would be and again not only I
think you'll have towns pulling their
hair out over these minor intent to Cuts
being filed um you're going to have that
um we're already hearing from towns on
some of these exemptions saying
look um we're doing we're we're we're
spending quarters to get nickels you
know we're spending a lot of time
administratively to
pursue not a lot of tax dollars to do
that where there's no tax dollars I
think you're going to have Town clerks
uh we'll give them your personal phone
number and say this was aon's idea but I
think that's going to I think you're
going to get pushed back there and and
uh I don't I just don't see it as a a
workaround thank you representative R
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
stock for taking my question first of
all I love Bob the chopper I think we
need t-shirts oh Chopper Bob chopper Bob
chopper Bob I kept thinking Bob the
Builder but um I want to understand a
little bit more about um the the the the
Choppers so um people or firms that
would go in do a Timber cut okay they're
they're in one level it do they are are
any of them the same people who a
homeowner would would call up to say gez
I need to have eight or 10 trees cut
along you know my backyard or are those
two really separate um
providers no great question there's a
lot of crossover there um there there's
a lot of crossover um between between
kind of I'll call commercial Timber
Harvesters the big skitters the big
equipment but many times they'll also
get a call from a homeowner saying hey
we need we need some some trees removed
from you know some Hazard trees removed
from around the power lines or from
around our
house um can you do this as well and so
they they will do that and sometimes
they'll have folks usually they're young
young men and young women on their crew
that will climb and and do the topping
and and kind of cutting the trees down
so there's a lot of crossover there and
sometimes they'll even have a Forester
on staff so again e just like these
Timber sales come in all shapes and
sizes these logging companies can as
well um they'll have some of them will
climb and do that limbing and kind of
what you think of as arborist work
others will remove Hazard trees and then
there are some that I don't want to
touch that I just want to work in the
Woods leave me alone and I want to do my
commercial Timber cutting okay follow
up okay so those companies that you just
described that have the the the skitters
that whole thing they're going to be
aware of what the laws are around
cutting Timber around Woodland I would
expect especially if there's if they've
gone through your certification process
but are there also other players in this
in the tree cutting business who are
really
small um you know maybe the truck with
the
um um chainsaw they would you expect
that they would be familiar with the
wetlands laws some are and some aren't
you know it's it's like it's like hiring
a roofer it's like hiring a mechanic you
know you can you can take your car to
groni and have a big operation or you
can take it to the the person down the
street who has a one Bay garage um they
can both be they they both can be just
as knowledgeable and up to dat on in
that case automotive repair same with
Timber harvesting um in fact there are I
can think of off the top of my head
several young men that graduated from
UNH they um they're in this case a
couple of them are Foresters but they
also cut wood and they have a chainsaw
but they're you know very very sharp
very knowledgeable of the laws the rules
and and one of them even climbs and does
arborist work on the side as well so
it's again it's you can't really just
because I'm a single single chainsaw
person with a pickup truck that doesn't
necessarily mean they're not they're um
ignorant of the laws or the rules okay
thank you
questions you're making up for p lost
time thank you we'll get you to lunch
shortly thank you Mr chair
um I don't know how familiar you are
with
2279 um a lot of the the language in
there says no person no person no person
so my question is in that that case
who's at liability for for a violation
of 2279 is it the home is it always the
landowner or is it the person doing the
cut that's that's 229 is the basil area
law yeah yeah I mean you have six here
which is
harvesting yeah I that that's a good
Steve Sherman question I I I think the
as with many environmental laws
um there is
a kind of a culpable they call it a
culpable state where if I'm knowingly
going out in breaking the law versus
accidentally there's that's a
distinction but also there is at the end
of the day the
landowner the landowner it tends to be
the the ultimate person but in the case
of Basil area I know of instances where
it wasn't the landowner it was a Timber
Harvester um and they you know they were
the individual that okay you violated
the law you exceeded the basil area and
I think what's important to remember is
229 is not the short land protection act
so again another apple and orange
here when we talk about Shoreland
protection you all know because that's
an area of the law you you that falls
into this committee it's a very
different animal than basil area Timber
harvesting you know a Timber harvesting
operation where the nent to Cuts file
does not you know that falls under basil
area um Shoreland is you know count the
trees and shrubs and it's a different
world I don't know Steve how' I
do not bad I'll take that is
[Music]
good any other questions seeing
none thank you for your time and that's
o'clock
now
well thanks for the clock being reset we
know it's accurate thank you
representative Kelly for that um it's uh
11:00 and
at 1:00 and we're going to be having the
hearing on HB
1209 and I'll call to the to testify
representative thank you m thank you Mr
chair um this is in my opinion pretty
simple bill so what it would do is it
would allow people to tow people with a
boat or a jet ski um and not require a
Observer as long as the boat or jet ski
has Mirrors um sufficient to see the
person who's being towed um so this
wouldn't be if someone wanted to still
have Observer they could um but this
just wouldn't require one so long as the
driver of the boat where jet ski can
actually see the person who's being
towed and I think this is in line with
what um various other states do um not
requiring an observer so long as there's
um mirrors that allows the operator to
see the passenger being towed um and so
in cases of a jet ski a lot of jet skis
can only carry one person um some of
them can carry more but the ones who can
carry only one person they're
effectively unable then to use it to tow
people um which I think is somewhat
unfair um so in regards to a safety
issue I think it is still safe so long
as that person can see someone properly
in with mirrors um so the statute um I'm
amending headlink about a wide angled
mirror um I just replace that to be with
the mirror allowing the person to be
viewed um if the committee feels
separate language or different language
is appropriate to better address my
intent certainly I would support that um
but the intent of this is to not require
a third person so long as the um
operator can actually see the person
being tow in with mirrors and I'm happy
to take any
questions any questions for the
representative representative Veil
thank you Mr chair um thank you
representative for taking my question so
I'm looking this as an
observer shall not be required if the mo
motorboat is and a bunch of text here is
taken
out um starting on line five where the
motorboat shall be equipped with a wide
angle mirror um why is that being
removed if we want people to use a
mirror to observe the person that
they're Towing so under the present law
which um is just for water skiers only
you don't need an observe uh you don't
need an observer as long as um the
operator's 18 I don't really take issue
with that um the boat does have a wide
angle mirror but the really the limiting
section is and um on sentus six operated
within a slum course approved by the
American water ski Association I mean
that essentially just makes it so that
everyone needs an observer in the state
um so this would get rid of that
requirement so long as there is is a
mirror um and if um you want to keep the
language that the operator B18 I
wouldn't take an issue with that as
well thank you for taking my
question did sorry did I answer your
question or you did thank you okay thank
you any other questions representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you uh
representative Hines for taking my
question um you stated um that uh ski
craft which are essentially those onep
person Jet Skis
um aren't uh you know it makes it
difficult to to tow somebody are there
other cases or is that the case that
you're primarily concerned with here I
have a jet ski so personally that's what
I care about but um for boers I think
it's the same thing that other states
just don't distinguish that and do allow
boats to do it as well um so while the
boat might not be the limiting factor um
the amount of people required could be a
limiting factor so if it's just two
people that want to go out one's the
operator on to Tower they wouldn't be
able to do that under present law um but
this would allow them to do that as long
as the boat has Mirrors that can
adequately see the person being towed um
if the person who's being towed isn't
okay with that certainly they should not
they can either just not do it or get
someone else to wait till there is an
observer but um hope that answers your
question follow follow up thank you Mr
chairman I follow um
so um for the for the ski Craft um
because of course there are the the the
more common at least on a lot of lakes
these days are the three person ski
craft or jet skis that um and you you
often see people you know getting towed
on those but for the one person um if
somebody were to like get hurt which has
happened to my kids um how if there's
only one per one person Jet Ski how do
shore like they fall off the they fall
off they have a bad you know a bad flip
yeah so I don't my J ski kind of holds
two people so I don't know if the single
use ones you're talking about there is
no way to do that so um I guess the the
issue wouldn't be any different than if
it only holds two people and now your
Observer is that second person you're
still going to have the same issue I
guess you can leave an observer behind
in the water and somehow manage to get
the injured um person out but um I think
that's kind of a limiting thing with
really any jet ski potentially thank
you representative Ron thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so with your bill it's just
saying it's equipped with a mirror it
doesn't have any size so would somebody
um just be a up like a really small
mirror just to get away with it I mean I
mean the bill right I mean the statue
right now requires a wide angle mirror
with a viewing surface of at least 48
square in so I'm saying removing that um
doesn't would that increase the risk
that the operator would miss seeing if
the toe the person skiing had
fallen yes I know different states have
different mirror requirements ours um as
you just pointed out is the wide angle
one with 48 in um if if that's the
language that you feel is better I would
certainly support it if that's type of
mirror being required um so I would be
supportive of that type of amendment um
I just picked that language because it
it was easier I don't I mean at some
point yes people should not be using
small mirrors that are just way too
small that they can't observe the person
being
code okay followup followup because I
I'm wondering it seems in current
statute by having the larger mirror um
where they they specify it's got to be
48 square in that the operator would
have the benefit of their peripheral
vision in the mirror to notice if the
person being towed had fallen or is in
distress but just saying
mirror I mean anybody could be
interpreting that it could be just a a
small mirror and I'm just wondering
without the benefit of the peripheral
vision do you expect someone could go
without the peripheral vision and be
able to know if someone's Fallen so I
think one of the issues with the 48
square inch mirror is that's kind of big
specifically for a jet ski so I I
installed aftermarket mirrors on my jet
ski they're not 40 in um they are wide
angled it does allow me to view the
person behind um them behind me um but
it I just know it's not 48 in if I had
to guess it's it's at least four I think
it's roughly like 4X 4ish and I believe
other states that's kind of what they
were using so I think 48 square in is
kind of big um I perhaps the wide angle
part's important but um the reason I
just left it as it is is U my language
just says it allows the person to be
viewed so I mean if the mirror is not
doing its job that you can't view the
person I would say that's not complying
with the statute okay thank
you representative wolf thank you um
where does this come in and I didn't
have a chance to read it through but is
this only for Honor slom
course so the present law Yes mine gets
rid of that no so it allows it
anywhere the present law allows it uh
the present law doesn't require an
observer so long as the person's 18 and
it's a appropriate mirror and it's on a
Solem course I think really that's the
limiting thing of those three things um
so my um proposed bill would get rid of
all that and just not require it
anywhere on a public body of water um or
private body of water so long as there
mirror so follow up followup Mr so
anybody
can tow a water
skier as long as they have a mirror and
no second person required in the boat
any place on any Lake if this bill
passes yes that's the
intent and you don't feel that's a
safety house
I don't because the it's is in line with
what various other states do I didn't
take an exact I quickly did some
research online looks like a lot of them
were Southern States um but it is what
other states do I don't think it is a
safety issue because the at the end of
the day the operator is responsible for
that person um and if they're using the
mirror
appropriately um I see an issue so um if
the person being tow feels it's a safety
issue they just in my opinion shouldn't
representative I have one representative
if you'll take it um you made a comment
about approved slalom courses by the
American water ski
Association are there any approved SL s
slom SL slom courses in New Hampshire by
that group actually don't know because I
don't do that um perhaps someone of the
commit is more knowledgeable with it I
guess I just assumed there was if
there's law dealing with that but I
actually don't know the answer okay
thank you any other
testimony that's the next uh next
Sergeant
Seth Ali yes l IE of the Marine
Patrol good afternoon Sergeant good
afternoon Mr chair the state of New
Hampshire Marine Patrol is opposed to
this uh Bill there are uh some concerns
that the the state of New Hampshire
Marine Patrol sees with this uh been
with the department for 27 years been on
on the water many times the one big
concern that that the state sees is that
injured party should they fall how is it
to be rent rendered assistance to that
injured party with one boat operator and
an injured person in the water how does
that boat then get back to that operator
or injured person sorry and then get
into the water to then render
assistance at that point when you have
that Observer on board that we say has
to be 13 years or old and capable of
rendering assistance therefore that
person can get in the water I.E hold a
head up maybe stop some bleeding where a
tourniquet may be needed where where is
how do they then get back into that boat
um I could go on and on for many of the
uh boating accidents that I've been to
even when there are multiple observers
there and I think by taking away having
an observer there and having just a
mirror U could really impose some
significant injuries to the public out
there and or just that operator maybe
not seeing that person injured by just
mirror questions for the sergeant
representative will thank you and thank
you for taking my question do you see
any increase or decrease I should say
put it the other way in safety when you
have one person that has to monitor
where the boat is going and that same
person having to monitor the skier
behind her him or her yes I I would
agree um I myself am a water skier I
have a older ski booat and often I have
a mirror as well and we see it out on
the water often folks I myself sometimes
get caught up in it looking behind the
mirror is there you can stare at it but
often we find ourselves looking back
just to see peripheral what's out on the
other sides maybe not just right in with
what's in line with that mirror I think
we all see it out on the road I.E some
people using their phones and lean over
to look at something we often tend to go
that direction so now going back to your
co question you know hey I look over my
shoulder and now I'm not fall following
the direction where I was headed to
potentially could cause other safety
concerns out
you thank you Mr chair um a uh related
question um we've heard in other um
under other bills testimony and other
bills that there's been increase in the
amount of traffic on some of our water
bodies I know that you know um on days
like Fourth of July or um Labor Day for
example they Lakes can get pretty busy
um could there be uh in addition to sort
of looking over your shoulder is there
this notion that you're either focused
on person behind you or the traffic
around you or missing the person behind
you falling off because because you got
to deal with
traffic yes I would agree with you
entirely uh I think that as a whole here
in New Hampshire we've seen a large
increase of boating Rec ational due to
co due to everything that's happening
out there right now and on those busy
weekends where like you said sir you
know trying to watch other boats because
we all know there's no yellow white
lines out there it's can be a
free-for-all and now having to watch a
boat coming from my starboard side oh I
got to keep eyes on that and oh by the
way I need to be looking in the mirror
to see if that person falls and then
again I really can't stress enough is
that rendering assistance I myself had a
person wakeboarding fell down said he
had back problems my n my passenger on
board hopped in real quick to render him
assistance whereas I would have had to
get out of the boat now get back to the
boat to try and get that person up into
my
sergeant seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr chair is there
hb29 I'll say again anybody else to test
bu on HB
1209 on the blue sheets representative
against online I have two in support
three
oppose and no
neutral great thank you very very much
thank you representative I'll close the
hearing on
2:00 on
1229 purchase and sale of real estate AB
budding public
Waters Mr chair yes ma'am um I have um
an an amendment to the that Shoreline
septic system bill that I introduced a
couple weeks ago um would you recommend
I hand it out now or wait until the
executive
session I would recommend both being a
conservative person because I think it's
good to have it ahead of time but I know
some of the people aren't here and uh
the clerk will probably want a copy for
the record then so I I would do both
representative wrong here so if you want
good
Mr
chairman representative wolf um is there
any possibility can we go into a can we
exec a bill now uh I was asked a
question about executing the bill and I
have a hesitation to EXA the bill when
recommendation okay um you could email
him because we're having a ton of bills
we're executing next week at 9:00 a ton
of them so if it's a bill you think is
short it may already be on that list if
not we could ask the chair to add it yes
no I I'm wondering if we could do it now
because I detect a unanimous decision on
this last I think before he left the
chair says all the bills we do today
will be on exec next
week okay so we're not going to do it
question
too
that's
just
start
e
9 relative to the purchase and sale of
any interest in Real Property AB budding
public Waters I call forth the prime
Ron thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee um for allowing me this
opportunity to introduce you introduce
hp1
1229 um this bill came about because
anodot I have heard so many stories
about um new Property Owners they they
purchase property that is subject to the
Shoreline protection water quality act
and they're not aware of that and they
go around and what we've heard in
previous test when they cut down all
these trees they may fertilize their
yard they have other behaviors that
really harm the lake and the harm that
it causes can last Generations you
clearcut along a Lakefront it takes a
long time to um reverse or at least get
back to the steady state of the
stability of the of the shorefront um it
leads to erosion it leads to um uh run
off and we've heard earlier about the
hazards that these activities cause to
the lake and the Damage it creates
especially adding phosphorus to the lake
so this this bill is a simple bill that
when property that is subject to the
Shoreline protection act that when it's
being transferred from a bu a seller to
a buyer that part of that transaction
has to include notification that the
property is subject to the ACT Dees does
have a document called a minimum
standards document which summarizes what
are the expectations of a Shoreland
owner um and so upon at that closing or
that transaction the buyer would be
given that document so there's would be
no reason for a buyer at a later point
to say oh I didn't know I wasn't
supposed to do that because they were
notified that they have extra
responsibilities in purchasing this
product property that there a butter is
public Waters that are under the the um
Guidance the the protection of the
state so um I think it's it's pretty
clear I do want to bring attention to an
amendment that I passed out to you um
when I was in discussions with Dees they
raised concerns about the amount or just
the
violation um and it it's in the original
bill it starts at line
16 it says any violation of this section
coupled with any violation of RSA 43b or
the Department's rules and regulations
should be result in a civil penalty
against a property owners of $1,000 for
a first time offense 2,000 for a
subsequence offense uh payment of the
Civil penalty shall be remitted to the
Department of Environmental Services
civil penalty shall not preclude a
judgment inequity or law that whole
paragraph has been removed so
essentially that um the you know at
closing if I'm sure many of you have
purchased property you're signing
notifications that you've received
notification of this notification of
that they would also receive a
notification that this property is
subject to the Shoreline protection act
and here are some minimum standards for
um
compliance um I know that the department
has raised some ISS issues with um
having receipt of that signed or the
receipt of that notification going back
to them my original conversations that I
recall with Ds said they have no problem
they receive a lot of these signed
notifications but they would just keep
them on file because um in the future if
that property owner is found to be in
violation they can't claim ignorance
they can't claim oh I didn't know I
wasn't supposed to do this because there
is that sign notification on file and I
do want to bring your attention to uh
testimony we heard for HB 1103 that was
the bill we heard January 17th that
would um clarify the enforcement of the
shoreline protection act if you remember
presently under statute the department
has to show that there has been a
violation but also show that there's
been direct damage to the lake and that
the person um knew that it was a VI
violation and that they have to
demonstrate good faith effort if you
remember it was kind of confusing so we
just the the the hp103 is just to show
that we can enforce this act if there is
a violation period but during that
testimony um uh Sarah Holland from the
New Hampshire realtors association
raised the issue of notification and she
had said current statute is not working
to protect public Waters the notific
ation piece is important and this is
that notification piece so I think that
this will go a long way to educating
property owners that when they are
buying property that is subject to the
Shoreline protection act that there is
added
responsibility so I would be happy to um
answer any questions you have any
representative well I have one
representative
we have been discussing the requirements
by the real estate board and uh Realtors
of notifying people about the um
Shoreline protection act in the septic
system inspections that are required so
if there's a penalty for not doing that
because my understanding is every buyer
is going to get that
report why do we need to have enough the
law saying they need to be notified of
the Shoreland protection act when
they're getting the inspection of the
septic system that tells them it's under
the shoreline protection act um well
thank you very much Mr chair for the
question septic systems are just a very
small part of what the shoreline
protection act is about um what what it
is it has to do with where structures
can be um there there's certain setbacks
that go beyond a local
zoning um there's like I mentioned
before the cutting of trees removal of
vegetation um many there are many other
behaviors than um not maintaining a
functioning septic system that goes into
that Shoreline protection act so just
just getting a report on their septic
system is not notifying them of all of
these other responsibilities that they
would
have thank you any questions
representative wolf thank you and thank
you for taking my question I think that
um I've got a couple of phraseology
problems in this document I think it's
fine that they have to be notified right
now a buyer has to be notified of the
possibility of lead paint of radon and
all those things and I think the Shand
um you have in here that the buyer has
to acknowledge and understand the
document I have real trouble
understanding that whole Shoreland
protection document so I would suggest
that that may be amended in there and
um just keep the owners on the seller to
deliver notification that they may be
subject to the Shoreland
protection okay
noted thank you very much representative
wolf and I'll work with you on that
Amendment okay thank you representative
Donell thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question representative
R uh I purchased a couple houses my
lifetime and when you're in a closing or
when you're in that mine there is so
many documents you are just literally
signing yes yes yes how do you think
this is going to stand out and is there
any um this may be a question back to
Dees or someone else with um how do you
elevate this to have them go get either
maybe Education certification other than
just they may sign this and this would
just be another thing they sign and say
yep check done but never really read the
document that's a great question and
I've been in that situation
myself
um if I I'm trying to get into the mind
of a buyer who's buying waterfront
property that's really an exciting
opportunity a lot of people don't have
that and when someone does that they
know that they're getting property that
is kind of special they're buying it
because maybe it's going to be a a
second home or um a retirement home
where they've saved they've always
wanted to live on Waterfront so I think
during that closing and they see oh
Shoreline protection act I think that's
going to stand out to someone because
they're likely buying that property
specifically for the
shoreline and this notification would
alert them that that comes with added
responsibilities that you're not going
to have for any other property you know
raidon um all those things
representative wolf mentioned
and lead lead paint um I was just on a
bill about we had it was we were lead
arsonic there's a lot of things even if
you have a private well that you have to
be notified on um and most people would
just say oh yeah that's that that's
expected but not everybody expects that
they have to comply with the shoreline
protection act um so I think that it
would be something that would stand out
more than a
typical other notifications but
additionally it does Prov provide some
uh protection if 1103 doesn't pass um
this gives us a way of showing PE hey
you were notified you were aware of your
responsibilities or that you're subject
to the Shoreline protection act because
right now someone can com someone could
clear cut the the front of their
property of trees and DS comes in and
they're investigating it and the person
can say I didn't have any idea I wasn't
supposed to do that and they can't
enforce the statute under that
circumstance but if they know that
someone says no when you bought this
property you were aware that you were
notified that you're under the shoreline
protection act it it just that by itself
establishes awareness of they were they
had there was a compliance that they had
to agree
with
follow follow thank you um
30 well 20 years ago when I first bought
my I my first Lake home I uh I did not
have that same mindset now that I've
lived on a lake and now that I've been
engaged with it more and more absolutely
I have that mindset that you're you're
talking about um I don't think everyone
has the same mindset that is like this
is special this is something it is but
they may not have the full understanding
of that and I I applaud this bill in
many many ways because I you know had
wish I had the in the more fortitude
back than 20 years ago um so I would I
would love to be part of your amendment
process to see if we can figure out a
better way to make sure the education is
is something that they may take a class
on they may do something outside of this
but I think just
stating sorry I'm supposed to have a
question I'd like to just help with this
a little further I would appreciate it
and at the minimum it's a star
representative I mean I mean it it's
really the
basic um start to just get people aware
that guess what there is a shoreline
protection act and if there's things
that we can do beyond that to give them
specific education on just how do you
maintain a lawn when you're within that
zone uh without using fertilizer and I
do believe I'm not exactly sure maybe um
Miss Forest can educate us on this but I
I think there are tutorials on DS's
website on how to be a responsible
Lakefront owner and I know New Hampshire
lakes does with their Lakes smart
program they do a lot of education on
that representative Vale thank you Mr
chair um thank you representative run
for putting forward the bill and for
taking my question so I was just looking
online at the submissions and I noticed
a question that I don't think has been
answered yet and so the person who wrote
in said I have a con concern that a
failure to accurately represent degree
of Conformity to the Shoreland
protection requirements would lead to
liability claims against the seller do
you see that as an issue with this
bill I don't um I don't really
understand it as well as I should to be
able to answer it so what you're saying
is that if a buyer realizes that the
seller has not complied with the
shoreline protection act then
they may be liable the buyer may be
liable so for instance if the seller
cuts down the
trees there's a
buyer um would they then assume the
liability of that
violation that that's a good question to
ask D yes I would think no because I
think the violation is on the offender
um so it would have to be the offender
would be the Violator somebody I don't
think somebody in that situation assumes
the Li liability from someone else but
I'm not a good person to answer that
question but that's just what I think my
personal opinion I think that's a good
answer thank you representative thank
you other questions for the
representative representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative R for taking my
question um so you like you said you
struck out um sub paragraph 4 um you
left sub paragraph three which is the
reporting of the signed form to Dees is
that um intended for the um sort of for
that awareness if there's later
enforcement is that the intent yes okay
lont do you have a copy of that minimum
standards document no I don't when I ini
initially proposed this LSR to OS um I
was actually coming up like that they
need to present a one or two pager that
summarizes a landowners responsibility
under the shoreline protection act and
the attorney the OS attorney got back to
me and said they already have he he had
been in touch with Dees and they he said
they already have this minimum standards
document so he asked if he could just
put that in statute and I said does it
serve the function of the document I was
proposing he said
yes okay thank
you any other
questions I have one more followup if I
might um being a real estate
transactional attorney I can tell you
people a closings don't read hardly
anything you give them because they just
want to buy the property but you want to
notify people I'm wondering why didn't
you put this notification under 477 with
the Arsenic and the lead paint and all
the other
notifications and then say that that
should be added to the laundry list and
those notifications do have some uh
liability concerns and they're mentioned
in there about what if you failed to do
this I just wondered would this not be
more appropriate under 477 than
483 well um my intent of keeping this
separate is that it's only going to
apply to a very small number of
properties relative to um the the
general notification like the r Snick
many of those those only apply to homes
with private well Waters private Wells
so the the notifications dependent on
the type of property I don't I I mean my
understanding is that the when there's a
real estate transaction the types of
notifications that have to be made are
dependent on the property and the if
there's sewer are a septic so it it
doesn't apply to everybody so I wanted
this notification to only apply to
properties that would H that would um be
under that
act rather than part of a laundry
list thank you any other questions for
the
representative saying none thank you
okay thank
you since amendments were mentioned I'm
going to ask uh Darlene for of the D if
next good afternoon my name is Darlene
Forest I'm the current Wetland Bureau
administrator Shoreland protection Falls
underneath the Wetland Bureau at this
time within the Department of
Environmental Services I'd like to thank
the committee for hearing our comments I
have already passed out the Department's
letter of testimony um to summarize it
essentially states that the department
is not supportive of a fine for failure
to submit the notice because
it seems somewhat disproportionate for
administrative
um administrative process failure when
compared to actual environmental
outcomes failures that we sometimes see
in addition the department
is not in favor of being The Keeper of
the signed document the department does
not believe that it is necessary to have
a signed document in order to enforce
Department very much appreciates the
intent of this bill and thanks
representative rung for filing it and
advancing education of Shoreline
protection issues we wholeheartedly
support that aspect of this bill for
education and notification of new
owners however um on the ISS issue
of accepting the signed document there
are some things
that we would note that makes that
document
itself not of significant value to us in
the compliance uh in the compliance
realm one laws change if the Law changes
the document is only certifying that the
person knew what was in the fact
sheet not the entirety of the law at the
time that they signed or they purchased
the
property so as soon as you've changed
something on the fact sheet or in the
law you start to degrade the value of
that certification
document uh we would note that within
this language since there's been
discussion of an amendment it talks
about the minimum standards
document which indicates it's a very
specific document it may be wise to say
a minimum standards document to to be
prepared by the
department and we might want to be
specific about what that
explains that way if the Law
changes we update the fact sheets with
the changes to the to the statute or the
rules and it
becomes there's no question at that
point the right document there's no
issue with updating the document it
allows it to be a more updated exchange
of
information with the certification uh
many properties are held by trust many
Shoreline properties are held uh by
llc's by multiple members of a family
does every individual have to sign it um
there are frequently times when we deal
with trust because people don't want us
to know who owns that property um that's
one of the weird and unique things about
New Hampshire that some people like
about it is is the fact that there's a
certain amount of anonymity sometimes
with being here and they will not I can
guarantee we will not be getting owner
signatures on these documents for all
Shoreland properties we will be getting
trustees or whoever has the power of
attorney we don't believe that affects
our ability to enforce but it goes to it
goes to why the department doesn't
believe we need to have that particular
document in our
possession if a violation has in fact uh
occurred absolutely hope the education
makes it all the way through to whoever
is the owner and who is staying there
and asking for work to be
done but we don't think that that
document is crucial for our ability to
do it to proceed with compliance
actions
um I also want to remind everybody
because it's a common problem that we
all say Lakes shorland protection act
also applies to title Waters and it
applies to many Rivers which are fourth
order which might not be as big as we
sometimes Envision so and for those
folks it may just be that you out and
buy a property that has a river in your
backyard
so please keep that in mind it's not
always I'm looking for Shoreline because
I finally got to be a shoreline it's
just so happens I have a river in my
backyard
so with that said if you folks have any
questions be happy to answer
questions representative wolf thank you
and thank you for taking my question
um yes I agree with you that the
document can change over time but at the
time of a
purchase would this give you a date
certain that you could have another tool
enforcement it won't be
detrimental but I suspect the argument
that we will hear is this is a fact
sheet not the law and I only read the
fact sheet I might have missed some
aspect of the law
so yes it is a
tool assuming that you have the right
signature on it
and
that comes into play I I know how I've
experienced enough of these Enforcement
cases that I can sense the argument that
will come through and if the fact
sheet if signing the fact sheet becomes
what you're responsible for that fact
sheet be had better be awfully
good follow follow
up um when I was talking with repres
representative run we talked about a
notification that the buyer is aware
that the property may be subject to the
Shoreland protection
act without being specific but it puts
the buyer on notice would
that if we modify to that those terms
that they may they have purchased a
property that may be subject to the
shorel protection
act um I issue is not the Department's
issue is not so much with the exact
language of it the Department's issue is
whether or not the certification has to
be filed and kept by the department and
no and so it it the language would not
be better or worse per se understand
that we would not rely on it as critical
to making the case
okay thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony
Realtors good morning Mr morning gez
already screwed up good afternoon Mr
chair and members of the committee thank
you for uh taking my testimony I do have
a a prepared testimony but I thought I'd
go a little bit off script based upon
some of the Q&A that's come earlier
um and I just say uh overall for the
record my name is uh Chris Norwood I am
a real estate agent in the state of New
Hampshire I reside in Portsmouth uh I am
the principal of nii Norwood group a
commercial real estate brokerage firm
with offices in Portsmith and Bedford
and I am the
2024 uh public policy chair of the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors for
which I'm speaking today um so the
Realtors are opposed to this bill um I
appreciate apprciate uh representative
Run's um uh amendment that would remove
the $1,000 fine I think that we'd have a
concern there about the penalty um as I
look down the bill and hearing some of
the testimony it sounds like there's a a
discussion of the bill being a tool for
education for the people who um would
otherwise inhabit the property along the
shoreline or an enforcement tool for the
dees for those who um perhaps take
advantage or don't follow the Shoreland
protection act um and and as it relates
to the education piece um Mr chair I'd
like to just quickly discuss uh RSA 477
so RSA 477 are notifications that have
to take place prior to the transfer of
title and I just make a distinction and
I know representative wolf you raised
this earlier um RSA 4774 a are
notifications so that's raon arsenic
lead paint and I believe soon to be p
which was previously approved by this
committee um so the the notification
piece is that statement that says this
exists I think it outlines your question
of this property may contain uh it may
be by the shoreline uh as opposed to RSA
4774 C and D which include property
specific disclosures this property does
have this water system it does have this
sewer system it perhaps has uh
insulation of this type if it's going to
be used as a residential dwelling so
there's a distinction in my mind between
the language of notification and
disclosure but none of those documents
have a separate third-party state
sponsored form uh the minimum standards
form which must be signed at the time of
closing and remitted to the dees and
that's another component that we have a
concern about obviously we had the
aformentioned concern about the
liability to the the seller of the
property if they didn't uh have that
form properly filled out in the Thousand
fine but we do also have a concern
relative to having a separate form be
signed and it becoming part of that um
that that uh pile of paperwork that
folks perhaps do not understand uh let
me just take a quick note as to some of
the other questions that came forth um
it was mentioned earlier about um some
of the other tools that the uh Shoreland
protection act address and uh we
certainly are supportive overall of
keeping healthy rivers and streams and
lakes uh I believe there is a bill hb1
1293 which is an Ena presently that uh
deals with phosphorus and runoff which
we are supportive of um I'll also say
one of the concerns that we had in the
bill is this bill also uh addresses this
form being signed by leses of property
and for that matter it also deals with
condominium owners of property and uh
neither broadly speaking less ease of
property and um condominium owners who
may not uh have a a full vote at the
board of the condominium don't have a
direct um say certainly leses don't over
cutting of trees or or what type of um
you know vegetation goes on the property
so there's some of this bill in the in
the first section that deals with leses
and uh and obviously condominium owners
and I just have a concern there that
they really don't have any need to be uh
trained in this regard and I'd say
finally um from the realtor
standpoint the the number of properties
that are along the shoreline that
transact every year um
is
probably I I we can get the better
research but I believe what I've read is
somewhere between 2 and 4% of all
Shoreland properties transact every year
and the reason I raised that is perhaps
there's a better tool if to to raise
this above the education barrier so it
doesn't get buried in the paperwork at
the at the time of transaction perhaps
you could uh have the municipality or
Dees directly notify these Property
Owners on an ongoing basis um rather
than wait for all of the transactions to
happen in a given year would take you
know 30 plus years for all the
properties in the state to necessarily
transact and educate all those owners
whereas we could notify them directly
either via Dees or directly through the
municipality so um apologize for going
off script but I hope that that uh may
have been a little bit more fruitful
based upon the conversation and I'm
happy to answer any
questions
any
questions representative
Derby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um so I totally
understand the like you don't want the
form signed it sounds like Dees doesn't
want the form signed either um I can't
tell quite I understand that you also
said I'm trying to rephrase to make sure
I understood it correctly that you said
that um there might be a better better
education method than notifications but
if there were notification ations um
would it uh be reasonable to you know
amend 4774 D which is where the
notifications are to include Shoreline
notification um and uh include a
reference to you know the the the best
guides practice which is you know the
what's referenced here the minimum
standards thank you representative for
the question um certainly if it were to
go
into the distinction I have between Ford
C and D in 4A uh excuse me RSA 4774 a is
4A goes back to representative Wolf's uh
point is this property may be in the
Shoreland or it may not be there there's
a conditionality to it whereas in uh 477
C and D it's referencing specifically
this property does have this type of
water source this it does have this type
so um I don't want to get too hung up on
that but I I think if it were to go into
4 a which is the notification section
which then would contain arsonic lead
paint Ron and soon to be P so one could
argue yeah that that would be a good
place to start with a notification
um it it certainly would uh address the
issue of someone who is transacting a
property and having it disclosed
currently Shoreline protection does
exist in our state disclosure form
already um because of the septic
requirements so that is on page two of
our four-page disclosure form so the
buyer already is acknowledging it in
that location uh whether or not they
should have a separate location as well
discuss representative
Donell thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question do you know if the
gis database contains the inform about
which properties are actually in
Shoreline
protection thank you representative for
the
question I would
say on a personal level I'm not 100%
sure and I know I'm going to mix two
different databases here but I know like
for flood insurance and that's not what
we're talking about today the Army core
data uh has been you know historically
inaccurate as it relates to uh that so I
always take the gis data with a bucket
of salt um and I think it's always a
trust put verify and I would certainly
lean to the dees or other experts to say
whether or not those uh GIS maps are
100% accurate thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr
chair and maybe going out of order um
Miss force can I ask you a technical
question because everybody keeps talking
about uh being on the river or being on
the
lake is it true that you can be under
the Wetland the Shoreland protection act
and not be on it if you're so many feet
from it yes and it frequently frequently
is the case the protected shorelands are
a distance of 250 ft from the reference
line on a lake if it's a natural lake
that will be the natural mean high water
line on an artificial
impoundment that is the limits of
Flowage so for instance to use
Newfound Lake uh Newfound Lake as an
example Newfound lake is a natural lake
which I believe the elevation the
natural elevation comes out to be
487.1
two um above datm the operating level
is 489 but we owe flow we own Flowage to
490 something thing
so that's not exactly easy to determine
especially given the variability of
Newfound Lake during a
season so uh
in if you only own if you own one of
those properties on newfound Lake that's
between for instance Westshore Road and
the lake that property is only 75 ft
deep so the person on the other side of
the road who's not actually against the
lake is also in the 250t buffer
and it's difficult for them to know
without trespassing onto the person
across the
way just how
far that extends back on their property
it's also a horizontal measurement as
the surveyor would measure it is not
something where you put a tape measure
down at
grade so uh reference lines are variable
based on the type of the water body on a
river it's the ordinary high water line
uh quite honestly with the events if the
river floods and the you have severe
bank
erosion yeah that line does move um and
it takes a little while for us to
determine what the long-term line will
be so there's a there's an issue of
variability sometimes in the reference
line the question was asked about the
gis layer the gis layer is only as good
as what it was based on frequently
they're based on the USGS maps and those
USGS maps were based on aerial photos
that I think the most recent data is
1983 so it's somebody who is doing um
aerial inter aerial photo interpretation
it's where the waterline was on the day
that the photo was taken as determined
from someone looking at it from 30,000
ft which experts are they're excellent
at it's a lot of variability um on an
old set of photos so
we would tell people not to rely on our
GIS system unless you build in at least
a 50 foot buffer onto the
buffer just to be cautious well thank
you very much appreciate you answering
that question thank
you Andrea Laro of New Hampshire Lakes
bill hello again good afternoon I'm
Andrea lro the president of New
Hampshire lakes and we are here in
support of the intent of this bill uh
New Hampshire Lakes we represent about
275 Lake Associations throughout the
state um and a couple thousand uh Lake
enthusiasts and there are many more
experts in the room here today than I on
what what part of the law this should
fit into but uh we are fully supportive
of providing another providing a
mechanism of notification to new
Property
Owners um to raise awareness about the
Shoreland protection act and the
Shoreland protection act in its entir it
extends much more than a septic systems
uh for those property owners who do read
all the forms when in closing and I
happen to be one of them um there may be
some others like me who would read all
the forms and find out something that's
really useful to them find out how uh
they can live in a lake friendly way how
they can manage their property in a lake
friendly way and a legal way to help
protect their investment along that
beautiful water body whether it be a
river or a lake or whatnot um and could
could also help them stay out of trouble
um I've heard some great comments today
about you know how this may not be you
know effective with every single
property owner but at this point you
know it takes some folks what they
saying seven times to hear something to
really learn it and internalize it and
this is just another way we think of
helping people understand um the act and
again how it how it can benefit them and
um benefit the the lake or the water
body they near so I encourage uh again
the experts in the room to figure out
the best way to make this this happen
but again we support the intent of it
and I'd be happy to answer any
questions any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you and my final pink card Jason stock
New Hampshire Timberland Owners
bill good good afternoon good to see you
again after lunch um I'll be really
brief we our policy committee re
reviewed this and you know we do have
property owners that do have land raw
Timberland that does have you know as
you heard earlier a bus of river or
would be would be kind of shorefront
property and
so when we reviewed it in that
context um you know our thought thought
was you know this adds another provision
to the real estate transaction and not
unlike the discussion we had earlier
this is we see this as an issue of
education and mandating another document
another
notice um we have to believe there's
another way to do this um
that instead of just mandating another
requirement that as you heard earlier
could or could could not be used as a
point of liability or something that
could hang up who knows but again we
just looked at this and thought there
has to be another element of this and
you know for that reason we just said
look you know we're happy to work with
anyone that wants to look at this but
again we just couldn't support yet
another mandate that it really wasn't
clear that it's necessary and that there
there has to be a better way than the
state coming in and saying thou sh um
you know even if I own a piece of
Timberland I sell it to another
Timberland investor I'm not sure what
they're I I won't I won't know what they
are going to do with it presumably
they'll own it and continue to manage it
as Timber but if they decide to put a
camp on it I'm not a mind reader I'm not
going to know that and again we don't
want to run into a situation we'll say
gez I didn't give them a notice cuz I
thought they were going to just manage
it for growing
trees and turns out they didn't so
having said that I don't have a whole
lot to add to the concerns and
discussion that occurred earlier but
happy to continue the dialogue with you
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony that was easy thank you okay I
don't have any more pink cards about
call it out is there anyone else to
speak on HB
1229 second call anyone else to speak on
hb1 1229 seeing no one approaching the
mic I'll close the hearing on HB 1229
and at 3:00 we'll start the hearing on
e
says come on we're at the 3:00 hour
we're going to have a hearing on HB 1249
and we'll call up the prime sponsor
representative
Spain
thank you members of the committee and
Mr chairman for uh hearing my bill uh I
brought this I'm not a I don't own a
boat and I don't water ski uh I've done
a lot of power snorkeling because I
couldn't get up on the skis and just got
pulled underwat behind them but um but I
met a constituent on the golf course
this last summer and um he started
talking to me about the confusion in the
current RSA and the way that it's
written up and I looked at it and I I
agreed it wasn't it was kind of vague in
a lot of areas for when you're towing an
inflatable and the RSA was written
focused mainly on water skiers and that
makes sense because it's from quite a
long time ago and things have been added
over the time aquaplanes and stuff have
been added over the years there was
nothing in there that specifically
addressed the Inflatables and there was
confusion where the law had been changed
to allow if you have up to six people
people being towed you need two spotters
but if you have three you only need one
and that was a change made many years
ago but the question was well if I've
got three people on One inflatable why
am I being told sometimes by the officer
that I need to have a second Spotter and
other times the officer thinks that's
fine I said well we can clarify that and
we can also add in a safety measure to
say no more than two Inflatables should
be towed behind the boat at any time cuz
that lines up with the two water skiers
that you can pull unless you have a
special permit so what I tried to do uh
was add in language that clarified when
you need one spotter when you need two
spotters and how many Inflatables you
can pull behind yourself while keeping
the safety
intact and since this is not my area of
expertise if there's anything the
committee thinks could be worded better
or changed I have no problem with an
amendment um I am strictly here to try
to clarify that RSA so that we can
include those Inflatables that are so
popular on the Lakes now and make sure
that uh there's no confusion between the
boers and the law enforcement and the
RSA and I'll take any questions if you
have them any questions for the
representative representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Spain for taking my
question one um minor concern I have
with the wording um is that it says um
no more than two persons shall be towed
on water skis aquaplanes or other
devices but then the very next line as
as the bill states it is when three or
more persons are being towed on water
skis aquaplanes or other devices um so
that seems to be contradicted and I
didn't ask for that line to be put in
there they did that uh at OSS in part of
their
clarification and I don't quite
understand that either because when it
was changed to allow the six people for
two spots ERS with the no more than six
persons could be towed on one or more
inflatable tubes uh or two persons on
water skis
aquaplanes that was pretty clear to me
so I don't know why they put the three
persons Toad on and that's why I said
this
is so yes followup thank you for the
followup I I just mentioned as well if
we go to the very last so I think you're
correct I my hunch is or I just did it
because they thought was that was right
but the very last line of the says not
not withstanding this paragraph uh two
or more two uh more than two skiers now
we're really talking about water skiers
yes maybe toad if a special permit is
issued so I don't think that um I don't
think that it was the intent was you
know you could tow two people ski with
one with one spot or originally would
you agree I would agree yeah okay thank
you and
uh as you can see a lot of that was
already language they just added in that
extra bit okay thanks a
lot representative M Ju Just a comment I
I I think that that the elsewhere it
says you have to have an
observer right and then but if it's
three or more so or more than two that's
where I think in 270 it
does and I and I think uh we have an
industry expert in the room and maybe
she'll clarify it or I'll bring up 270
but I think the intent is with that
language is when it's more than two or
same as three or more that's when you
need two
observers right because you can't have a
half
person I guess that was the end of that
question representative fail you have a
question yeah that question um so my
question just changed into um so you're
willing to amend the bills ABS it's not
my area of expertise and I would would
certainly welcome uh input from from you
guys to make this right I think it just
just it's very ambiguous the way that it
all is right now and uh and there was no
specific limit on how many Inflatables
could be towed uh anything more than two
and you're going to have lines Tangled
and things so I think for safety reasons
we need to put that in there along with
the
clarification thank you so much I mean
it doesn't look like it has
organizational problems but it does look
doable
too any anyone new to ask a
question s n representative
Derby thank you just one more um do you
have a the way I read this is um you
could have some of those tubes are big
right I mean you you can put four kids
on some of those especially four smaller
kids on some of those tubes um and why
I'm reading is if you got four kids on
one tube you would have one spot it was
that do you think that was that's
correct I was having them write it up
for one spotter per inflatable being
towed okay thank you and uh so that's
the way that I had had them do it yes
okay just wanted to make sure I
understood the in thank
you any other questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
thank
you uh Sergeant ali uh Department of
Safety Marine Patrol uh speaking against
the
bill
Sergeant Mr chair the Department of
Safety Division of State Police New
Hampshire Marine Patrol is in oppose to
this bill um we feel that there is some
safety concerns as it relates to having
those observers out there to assist with
those injuries I I know some of you
folks heard me speak before referencing
uh no observers for the boat or the
mirror um I think this mirror not the
play on words there but mirror is that
same type of uh analogy where in if in
fact you do have as it was explained two
tubes out there with four on one tube
and two on another tube and only having
one Observer or if in fact we stick with
the two
observers I still feel there is some
safety concerns there the state has
passed it it's gone to committees the
camps in such not back in
2011 with legislation passed with Camp
directors and the Marine trades to make
it so that if you have up to six tubes
you only need two observers um and I'm
sorry uh and I I feel that there are
some safety concerns when uh when we
start to break that down and and I would
also speak to that uh the water skiing
that we've always had the stance of no
more than two water skiers and to have
that thank you Sergeant any questions
for the sergeant representative hgan
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I I thought I just
heard you say that you could tow six
tubes yes sir under the current statue
right now you can tow one tube with six
people on it or six tubes with a person
you representative mchu thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
uh I'm just reading the current statute
and it seems like this proposed change
does clarify it it it says no more than
six persons May Toad on one or more
inflatable tubes and no two more no more
than two persons on water skis aquip
ples or other devices when three or more
persons are being towed to observers in
addition to the operator doesn't it make
sense so my question is doesn't it make
sense to clarify it by adding this new
language doesn't that make it
better I wouldn't disagree but I just I
I think we obviously as a group and I
apologize first time here D but making
sure water skis don't get caught up in
into this bill to have then ie6 water
ski is out there I think we can agree to
that I think when we start to
go as I read it for inflatables only one
Observer is required when using only one
inflatable and two observers for two
Inflatables but no more than two
Inflatables if in fact you have two
Inflatables and I don't disagree reading
from the
statue the state opposes it you know you
you're having people two
tubes again I wasn't here to to speak on
that for question back in 2011 follow up
now I understand what you mean um so
it's not two observers two Inflatables
it's potentially having two observers
and 12 people spread across two
Inflatables no you can't tow I'm sorry
to clarification no more than six people
may be towed on any other apparatus
other than water skis so in 2011 through
legislation through camps Marine trade
and uh in the state it came back to
being no more than six people on IE six
tubes or one tube with six people on it
observers am I not am I'm
sorry this seems to make it more clear I
mean everything else is already in
statute such observers shall be 13 years
notwithstanding special permit for a lot
of skiers all that that's all there this
just makes it more clear that if you got
two Inflatables you have to have one
Observer for each seems like that's a
good safety
thing I don't disagree but does the
statute not limit them to no more than
two
tubers correct me if I'm wrong current
statute says when three or more persons
are being towed doesn't specify this
this proposed legislation does clarify
it so it actually makes it more clear
says when three more when three or more
persons are being towed two observers in
a addition to the operator shall be in
the towing vessel to observers
everything else is existing statute I
just look at the amend or the amend to
here to put but no more than two
Inflatables may be towed at a time
current statute would say you are
allowed to tow six apparatuses wow okay
so so which do you think is better two
or six I I don't I my as a state
represents that we oppose this
bill representative
Arby okay but um thank you thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um I was under the impression that um
Department of Safety was opposing it
because the um number of um observers
was less than sometimes significantly
less potentially than the number of
people being towed and there weren't
enough people to you know help if
somebody was injured as opposed to being
opposed to it because you it was limited
to two towables instead of six
towables I wouldn't disagree with any of
the comments that are being made here
but as it stands you're allowed to tow
six people on One apparatus or six
apparatuses back as I said in 2011
through my notes that were disseminated
to me to speak on this prior to 2011 it
was one for one I enforced one for one
and I could go on many tangents of how I
would deal with the public out there who
you going to save of your four kids on
one tube with one Observer oh Jimmy you
don't like them let them go that has
changed to in 2011 now you are only
required to have two observers for six
amendment I'm sorry come again
sir I I think the question sergeant if I
could rephrase it for you I think the
question is how many observers does the
department
think you should have with
Inflatables however you determine six on
one or six with one on each uh this
amendment that representative Spain's
trying to clarify talks about how many
observers so that's why they asked are
you in favor or not it's like what would
the department like for a number of
observers with Inflatables Mr chair back
in 2011
this was block to the legislative board
to clarify from one for one and at that
point the camp directors the Marine
trades Association and Marine Patrol
with the legislation board came to this
realization we're going to allow six and
two
observers and you like
that in front of you right now recorded
no but that's not for me to say I have
documentations of this is how I that's
what I thought thought it sounded like
you didn't like the current law but this
proposal makes it it sounds like more to
your liking I don't just by what you're
saying I would can I speak on that if
you'd like I I I can speak to that only
because I don't like one for three it's
one for three you have one Observer for
three on this amended bill in my eyes is
all it's it's done is gone from six
tubes to two tubes that's all I see it
changing from It's Always still going to
have two observers which I still fall
back on to Seth alley not Department of
Safety one for one if I fall in the
water I want one of you to come rescue
me and if my wife's on board I want
someone else to hop in and now I add my
son on the back I want someone to hop in
to save
them but in
2011 the legislative board Marine trades
and Marine Patrol try to make it
better for the Marine trades for The
Aquatic paraphernalia out there and it
six and if I can ask you a question
Sergeant but representative Spain has
firm Inflatables only one Observer when
towing one inflatable but the first part
says I can have six people on the
inflatable so he's actually limiting
lessening the amount of observers as far
as you're concerned yes I would okay
that's that's why you're opposed
okay I got it thank you representative
Ron thank you Mr chair so in on line um
seven or end of six it says two
Inflatables but no more than two
Inflatables may be towed at a time so
with two Inflatables is that just
limited to one onone in current statute
because if you have six on one or one
for six
Inflatables would it be like three for
two like so if you have two Inflatables
is the maximum number of people six
still so would you have three on each of
those
Inflatables I can only speak to as I see
it we have apparatuses that are put out
there from a marine trades to say hey
this holds two people can you put three
kids on that yes you can
the designed for two people there are
hot dog tubes if you would call them
that will hold up to six people with
this current statue as Mr chair has
brought up you are now saying one
inflatable one person which in fact
could be six people on it as I read so
follow up Mr chair go ahead okay so with
the two Inflatables it's specified here
okay that would require two
observers those two Inflatables are you
saying that each one of those can hold
six
no there the statute States you can tow
no more than six people you can't have
six on one tube and six on that because
now you're towing 12 it's six no matter
what however you mix and match and make
up your six you can do I got it two on
one tube three on one tube and one on
another tube okay so with the two you
could have five on one one on the other
as long as it doesn't
six got it thank
you any other questions for the
sergeant one more
yes I I don't think it limits you it
says no more than six persons may be
towed on one or more inflatable tubes
where does how does that limit you to
six if you
have two
Inflatables in the in the proposed statu
here yeah or or in current statute
because I'm reading current statute and
I'm reading the part of the proposed
bill that's from current statute it
looks like there isn't a limit you got
have six times two is 12 have 12 which
is that would be a bit
crazy I mean so if we made it if we
fixed the language to make it one for
one one one like so you said so you
don't have to pick between your wife or
your kid would that be
better the state opposes this current
bill oh my God I got that I got that
part sir I don't he's not going to make
opinion let's not ask him you know I all
right representative sorry thank you
thank you Mr chair one more so after we
go that line that every was questioning
on it says when three or more persons
are being told you need to have two
observers so if you have the six with
one Observer you wouldn't be able to do
that it says right there when three or
more persons are being
towed you must have two
observers that's that does includ it
says it on all all the devices in all
the
devices if you want to put it flatables
that's fine too but I'm just saying it
does say on other devices so it says if
you have more than three people you have
to have
two like that I I would just as I look
at the Amendments that are in there for
inflatables only one Observer is re when
toing only one
inflatable which in theory could that
hold up to six people and I I don't just
agree with if if in fact they had six on
it they would have to have two and
that's what it actually says in line on
line four when it says when three or
more persons are being told you have to
have
two I wouldn't disagree disagree with
okay thank you I got a simple
sentence if it's a question to ask them
would it be more clear if this statute
just said for every person being towed
there was one there is one Observer
regardless of what they're being towed
on for every person being towed there's
one observer in the in the towboat and
then not withstanding this paragraph
special permit water show whatever you
know would would that make this all
simpler if we just changed all of it
deleted at all made it for every person
being towed there's one Observer can I
make a funny he said one no sorry um no
in the statute make the statute one make
the statute one sentence all I can refer
back to is in my 27 years with the
Department of Safety working from 18 to
now as a marine patrol officer and now
IE Sergeant back prior to
2011 it was one for one something
happened and and again I don't I I
doesn't yes it matters to me because I
take my job very passionately but
something through legislation said in
2011 we are going from one for one we're
going to do two for
six how about one more question for the
sergeant because I think you're getting
into the meat of the article rather than
asking them questions so if it's a
question actually going to go a
completely different angle here I'm not
going to talk about tax at all um thank
you for uh thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um the sponsor um
said that they were um his constituent
had um received contradictory
information at least that's what I
understood um from different um Marine
Patrol um officers in terms of the
number of spotters I'm wondering how you
know um if there are rules about you
know that specifically State how this is
going to be enforced and how this is
shared by you know Marine Patrol and and
the summer Patrol as well that comes on
part-time yeah so great question I think
that as it's been deciphered to me
when this first went into effect it was
New Hampshire M officers don't write
tickets on this go out there educate do
I think that when we see a stop sign
that says stop we all know that that
means stop but do I think that there are
some confusions when I'm out on his
constituent Lake and oh my God I see one
tube and and oh man I remember the
safety concerns was hey one for one do I
think there was some confusion do I
think that those officers we all make
mistakes I think think we've gotten
better at it but I still think there's
obviously mistakes can happen um I can
only Advocate that we have an all Hands
Day prior to the kickoff of the season
and we'd go over any law updates and
obviously this is one that was obviously
brought up because I remember it very
bially but I think there is some always
to any other
questions seeing none thank you Sergeant
for your test testimony and I would hope
someone would work with representative
Spain who's admitted that the bill needs
Amendment so that you might get an
amendment in uh quickly because um my
understanding is this bill is on for
exact next
week all the bills we did today I
believe uh the chair has put on plus
other bills we did before so if you have
an amendment on this bill um it would be
nice to get it in as soon as possible
even as a draft and then bring copies to
the exact session so double
up and with that that ends our hearings
for today unless anybody else wants to
testify Jody do you want to testify no
okay so I'm closing the hearing on this
bill uh HB 1249 and thank everybody for
participation
see
this